Grundsätzlich muss man ja sagen, wenn man auf Webseiten geht, wo man sich Kurse anschauen kann von Kryptowährungen, da wird man ja erschlagen.
Powercoin, Coin Dash, BTC, NEM, BCC Dash, Trum coin, Putin coin, Zero Cash, Zcash, WhiteBall, Ripple, Litecoin, Micromark, It. Pizzacoin, ETC, Stellar, Bitcoin Classic.
Wir müssen uns über Krypto-Geld unterhalten. Wir müssen mal wieder einen Blick wagen ins Kryptoland. Das ist ja irgendwie alles der helle Wahnsinn. Also wer soll denn da noch den Überblick behalten?
Hör mal.
Oder es kann natürlich auch sein, dass beide sozusagen so konfiguriert sind, dass sie immer alle Calls kriegen jetzt. Nur dass die Uhr die halt einfach ablehnt, wenn das Telefon sie kriegt. Also wäre interessant zu sehen, ob beide Telefone klingeln oder ob tatsächlich, wenn man mit der Watch von dem Telefon weg ist, die Watch quasi der Master ist, solange sie getragen wird.
Ja, es würde ja Batterie kosten. Das wäre doch viel besser. Die Uhr guckt immer mal über Bluetooth oder über WLAN, ist das Telefon in der Nähe. Und wenn das Telefon quasi aus diesem Nahbereich nicht mehr sichtbar ist, dann weckt quasi das LTE-Modul oder merkt es, ach, jetzt bin ich die Telefonstelle. Und meldet sich aktiv beim Mobilfunknetz an und sagt alles, was für die Nummer XYZ jetzt kommt, bitte an mich.
Die muss ich sowieso anmelden, wenn sie Daten schicken will und empfangen will. Also das Ding soll ja auch als Internetquelle dienen. Also angemeldet sein muss das Ding eh. Das schließt sich jetzt nicht komplett aus vom Netz. Nur dieses Call Routing, das ist dann halt eben so ein Sonderfall. Und das muss schon in irgendeiner Form netzseitig priorisiert sein, dass dann eben der Call auch tatsächlich an die Uhr weitergegeben wird.
Was für mich aber jetzt blöd klingt, ist, dass die Telekom wahrscheinlich für diese Freischaltung oder Übertragung auf die Uhr auch nochmal eine monatliche Zusatz vertragen.
Das ist nur in AT&T, bei AT&T in den USA bisher confirmed. Aber die nehmen ja für jeden Scheiß, die nehmen ja auch fürs iPad und so weiter nochmal extra Geld. Weil ja diese SIM-Karten so unglaublich teuer sind.
Aber das hast du doch bei der Telekom auch, wenn du Multisim hast.
Bezahlst du auch mehr im Monat?
Ich hab das definitiv gesehen. Also ich würd sagen 5 Euro ist das, was du mehr zahlst, wenn du zwei SIM-Karten haben willst.
Ja okay, ich hab das in meinem Tarif, es sind einfach die Multisims mit dabei, deswegen hab ich das grad nicht so auf dem Zeichnen. Kann sein, ja.
Bis 5 Euro fände ich das ja irgendwie, würde ich das noch zahlen, aber wie ich die Telekom kenne, wird das dann 12, 99 Euro kosten. Und dann bin ich raus.
Also derzeit ist es glaube ich 5 Euro.
Ja, aber es ist ja eine Apple Watch.
Kann sein, dass der Apple-Faktor drauf gerechnet wird, ja.
Ja, das ist ja virtuell, das ist richtig aufwendig. Naja, okay, gucken wir mal. Also könnte auf jeden Fall interessant sein, von der Optik sind sie nicht abgewichen.
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, wozu brauche ich die cellular Watch dann? Also telefonieren tue ich sowieso nicht.
Brauchst du es vielleicht nicht, gibt es ja auch ohne.
Telefonieren die Menschen in Amerika eigentlich mehr als wir?
Weiß ich nicht.
Weil dann hat man auch diesen hässlichen roten Punkt nicht.
Ja, das ist durchaus ein Argument und...
Und billiger ist ja auch so.
Wegen des roten Punktes, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich kann mir das irgendwie nicht, also schwierig, weil...
Ich habe nur einmal bisher tatsächlich über die Uhr telefoniert. Da muss natürlich das Telefon in der Nähe sein, damit das geht. Und das funktioniert auch einigermaßen. Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, das regelmäßig zu tun.
Na ja, wo es interessant ist, wenn du wirklich zum Sport gehst, nur mit der Uhr. Also ich gehe ja auch zum Sport nur mit meiner Laufuhr und habe nichts anderes dabei außer meinen Schlüssel. Wenn da natürlich was passiert, bin ich aufgeschmissen. So hast du halt mit der Watch immer noch die Möglichkeit, was weiß ich, bricht dir das Bein, keine Ahnung, was halt so passiert. Du bist angefahren. So kannst du halt immer noch rufen.
Jederzeit Probleme wie ständig. Meistens passiert der Uhr was, nicht mir.
Ja, dann kannst du nicht mehr anrufen, das ist richtig. Aber ich meine, das ist halt schon noch ein valider Punkt, dass du, wenn sie diese Sportschiene fahren wollen...
Die Nützlichkeit eines Telefons hängt immer davon ab, was für ein Leben man führt. Es mag Leute geben, die müssen einfach erreichbar sein, wollen erreichbar sein oder wollen vielleicht sogar noch beim Sport die ganze Zeit irgendwie mit ihren Freundinnen und Freunden quatschen.
Also ich sehe eher, dass es demnächst Leute gibt, die telefonieren, indem sie so das Handgelenk so ein bisschen anheben und dann einfach telefonieren und gleichzeitig ihr normales Smartphone haben, um dann quasi in den sozialen Netzwerken auf dem Laufenden zu bleiben.
Das kannst du aber auch ohne die Cellular Watch.
Ja, aber das machen sie immer so.
Nein, es gibt jetzt Airpods, Gregor.
Aber ich glaube, auch das macht man trotzdem mit Airpods. Ich glaube, das ist gerade innen so rumzulaufen.
Also ihr könnt das alles nicht sehen, weil das eine Geste ist.
Ich weiß von einer Schokolade ab.
Genau, diese Telefon-Methode.
Aber ich finde halt schon dieser Punkt, ich nehme das Telefon nicht mit zum Sport und habe dann aber die Möglichkeit, im Notfall jemanden anzurufen.
Ja, das ist ein guter Punkt.
Ich habe heute schon ein paar Stunden Sendung gemacht. Entschuldigung. Und bin früh aufgestanden und habe wenig geschlafen. Ich habe nur die Rolls-Ball-Taste nicht rechtzeitig gefunden.
Für mich ist diese Uhr vollkommen uninteressant.
Das ist völlig in Ordnung.
Das ist so eine Produktkategorie, wo ich einfach sagen würde, auch das sie jetzt noch telefoniert, finde ich eigentlich noch viel schlimmer. Also vorher hatte ich noch überlegt, aber das ist jetzt auch noch ein Telefon. Ich meine, das ist das Schlimmste. Das Schlimmste Use-Case auf meinem Telefon ist eigentlich, dass jemand dich anruft. Weil dich rufen doch nur noch Leute an, wenn es jetzt wirklich um schlimme Dinge geht. Oder um ganz eilige Sachen.
Das Schöne an der Uhr ist, dass du direkt auf der Uhr gucken kannst, wer ruft denn an? Ach, dann kann ich ja das ignorieren. Dann rappelt das noch eine Runde weiter.
Die Leute wollen halt irgendwie, was weiß ich, Apple Music Streaming hören beim Laufen.
Ist das mit der Netzneutralität vereinbar, wenn das dann über LTE läuft? Das habe ich nicht verstanden. Das Musikstreaming?
Das hat jetzt mit der Netzneutralität erstmal nichts zu tun.
Wo kommt denn die Musik her?
Na gut, Apple Music ist ein Musicstreaming-Dienst, wo du monatlich was bezahlst, um alle Musik, die dieser Katalog hat, zu hören, wann du das tun willst. Du kannst argumentieren, dass Apple den eigenen Dienst vor anderen Diensten priorisiert. Und das ist aber nicht nett, sondern eher Plattform-Neutralität. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das Fass aufmachen möchte.
Ihr habt ja gemerkt, ich komme ein bisschen aus einer anderen Zeit. Aber ich glaube, dass ich ja doch so ein bisschen mit den deutschen, bundesdeutschen Verhältnissen vertraut bin. Und dass es da eigentlich über LTE in der Regel hat man da so ein festes Volumen von Dingen. Und dann glaube ich, wenn man darüber Musik hört, also pro Monat...
Was ist ein festes Volumen von Dingen?
Von Daten.
Ja, man hat ein festes Volumen von Daten, aber das könnte ja nicht...
In meinem Fall ist das nur 5 Gigabyte.
Ja, Entschuldigung, dass du so prekär unterwegs bist.
Nein, das ist überhaupt nicht absurd, weil wenn ich... Normalerweise überall habe ich ja WLAN-Freies. Wieso soll ich... Also ich bin meistens...
Du hast nicht überall freies WLAN.
Also da wo ich mich meistens bewege, habe ich freies WLAN. Und deswegen brauche ich das nur dann als Notreserve, wenn ich irgendwo in Edgeland bin. Dann brauche ich halt...
Wir machen das jetzt mal ganz klar. Wir reden von Sporttreiben. Dafür ist diese Uhr. Die ist für Zeit angucken und für Sport. Und wenn das nicht deine Anwendungen sind, dann ist diese Uhr derzeit für dich nicht.
Greif mal ein bisschen einfach raus.
Es gibt noch mehr Anwendungen.
Ja, du kannst gleich noch ein paar Nischensachen, die vielleicht irgendwann nochmal eine große Bedeutung haben, da hinzufügen, aber derzeit ist das einfach das Ding. Und das ist auch bei mir genauso. Ich benutze das Ding für Sport.
Aber du hast es doch immer an.
Ja natürlich, warum soll ich es auch abmachen?
Ja, aber dann machst du ja nicht... 100% deiner Lebenszeit ist ja nicht Sport. Das heißt, das Gerät ist an deinem Körper in irgendeiner Form...
Ja, es gibt aber noch eine zweite Anwendung, die heißt Überleben. Ja, ich kann jetzt zu meinem Arzt gehen und sagen, guten Tag, hier sind drei Jahre lang vollständige Herzdaten. Komplett mein Herzschlag über mehrere Jahre, mehr oder weniger vollständig tagsüber. Das kann ich da abliefern. Und das ist einfach mal so ein Ding. Und das war ja dann auch noch ein Thema auf ihrer Keynote, dass sie exakt genau diesen Bereich jetzt ausbauen und sagen, wir messen jetzt nicht einfach mal nur mal, wenn es dich interessiert oder wenn du jetzt ein Training machst, sondern wir messen auch vor und nach dem Training. Und wir machen jetzt auch eine Analyse, ob denn dein Herzschlag irgendwie okay ist, weil die jetzt wahrscheinlich mittlerweile so viele Heartbeats weltweit durch ihr Machine Learning reingepumpt haben. Und bin mir sicher, dass sie das mit Machine Learning machen. Die haben einfach die Herzschläge von, was weiß ich, aber Millionen Leuten dadurch gepumpt und können jetzt Auffälligkeiten sofort einfach finden.
Vermeintliche Auffälligkeiten.
Vermeintliche Auffälligkeiten. Na gut, aber das ist halt für Diagnostik ist das schon ein wichtiger Punkt. Wenn du so ein Kammerflimmern hast, etc. das kannst du halt sehen.
Na ja, was sie halt jetzt versprechen, ist, dass sie das Vorhofflimmern wirklich sehen können, aber du weißt halt noch nicht, wie haben sie getestet. Und du weißt halt auch genauso nicht, wie beim Krebsvorsorge, wie die False-Positive-Rate ist. Weil was du damit nämlich auch machen kannst, ist einfach mal die Leute damit verunsichern und halt denen die ganze Zeit sagen, ey du hast Vorhofflimmern und der Arzt sagt dir, Freundchen hast du eben genau nicht.
Wenn sie ihr Training gut gemacht haben, dann gehen die False-Positives ja dann auch nach unten.
Letty, also du wählst nicht die FDP, das ist doch wieder hier Bedenken first, und digital second. Hättest du mit dem Vorfeld der Bundestagswahl dich ein bisschen weniger spitz bezieht.
Ja, du hast recht, Gregor. Ich sollte meine Bedenken, diesem wunderbaren Produkt.
Aber ich merke schon, dass dir der Christian Lindner gefällt, ne?
Ja, genau. Also ich stehe auf so schwierige, arg glatte Menschen. Auf jeden Fall. Kann mir mal jemand die Telefonnummer besorgen?
Aber Letty hat einen guten Punkt, insofern, als dass sie ja auch Arithmin entdecken können, wollen und die einem dann auch anzeigen. Und ich habe halt das Problem, dass ich schon immer Herzarithmin hatte. Und das letzte, was ich gebrauchen kann, ist, dass mir die Uhr dreimal am Tag sagt, dass ich eine Arithmi habe. Also das ist irgendwie so.
Die stressen dich halt doppelt damit.
Naja, genau.
Das ist halt.
Also das ist so, weiß nicht. Ja, ich meine, du kannst ja mal gucken, wie das wird.
Das heißt ja nicht, dass das Telefon nicht auch genau das lehrer oder die Uhrtelefon in dem Zusammenhang wahrscheinlich eher lernen kann, dass du genau das hast. Aber wenn du jetzt, sagen wir mal so, Herzinfarktvorstufe hast, dann kannst du auch da eine Arrhythmie haben oder nicht. Das kann mir keiner erzählen, dass das nicht jetzt gelingen kann, solche Dinge zu entdecken. Kann gut sein, das haben sie jetzt so noch nicht gesagt, aber ich wäre wenig überrascht, wenn das in naher Zukunft das Vorwarnmittel ist. Da geht einfach das Teil los und sagt, du solltest jetzt mal ganz schnell zum Arzt.
Dass sie diese Forschungs-Dings da machen wollten und dass es da diese App geben wird, wo du dann an der Forschung teilnehmen kannst. Und das macht auch dann deutlich mehr Sinn. Also eine große Datenbasis zu schaffen über einen gewissen Querschnitt der Bevölkerung ist da sicherlich sehr sinnvoll. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie jetzt schon die Lösung zu dem Kram haben.
Lassen wir mal die Experten sprechen. Hier im Chat meint einer, ich bin Arzt. Kammerflimmern fühlt man auch. Smiley, aber nur kurz, dann geht das Licht aus. Und mit Pulsdaten der Apple Watch kann man so gut wie nichts machen, außer vielleicht eine Bradi Cardi bei Sportlern.
Das habe ich mir nämlich auch gerade, ich habe extra deswegen das mit dem EKG nämlich noch mal aufgemacht, weil ich meine, aus einem EKG siehst du ja, ob jemand einen Herzinfarkt hatte, das siehst du an dieser Vorkurve. Und bei dem hast du ja andere Daten. Also für mich ist auch gerade die Frage, was eigentlich die Datengrundlage ist, die Apple da hat. Also es ist ja nicht dasselbe wie bei einem EKG. Und das scheint er ja da quasi auch genau zu sagen, wenn ich das jetzt richtig lese.
Also Bradikadi ist langsam Herzigkeit.
Ich bin ganz langsam Herzig.
Nein, das ist die Übersetzung des Originalworts. Bezeichnen in der Medizin eine Herzschlagfrequenz unter 60 Schlägen pro Minute beim erwachsenen Menschen. Gegenteil, Tachikadi, so so, bei über 100. Also ich bin kein Arzt, keine Ahnung, aber tendenziell ist einfach Health und Sport, das hängt da ohnehin zusammen und das ist halt das Thema.
Ja, aber es ist halt was, was sehr, also ich finde, die sind da halt so ein bisschen anmaßend, das jetzt so zu verallgemeinern, weil eben nicht jeder Mensch gleich ist. Ich finde das halt sehr, sehr grenzwertig, halt zu sagen, ja, wir können das jetzt, aber sie haben halt diese äußeren Umstände, halt diese einzelnen Personen nicht. Du kannst ja keine Diagnose bei jemandem machen, ohne alles zu berücksichtigen. Weil es ist halt so ein bisschen, ich finde das halt echt so ein bisschen dann grenzwertig, ebenso, weil es stressig, wie Roddi halt auch meinte, wenn du dann ständig diese Notifications bekommst, mit denen dein Herzstück ist zu hoch, weil wie soll Apple unterscheiden, dass das...
Das muss ja nicht, das muss es ja nicht sein. Ja, aber wenn du allein, also umso mehr so ein Gerät dauerhaft, ohne dass es mich jetzt besonders stört, Daten bei mich sammelt, die bei irgendeiner Diagnose unterstützend sein können, umso besser. Ich will ja jetzt nicht gleich unbedingt vom unmittelbaren Herzstillstand gewahlen werden, auch wenn ich da nichts dagegen hätte.
Für mich wirkt es so ein bisschen so, als wüssten sie jetzt nicht so ganz genau, was sie noch mit reintun sollen in die Apple Watch und dann haben sie halt so ein paar medizinische Edge-Cases noch dazu benutzt.
Das kommt jetzt, also ich würde mal kurz so ein bisschen so vorpiken in das, mit dem, was könnte bei Apple noch passieren, weil was nämlich interessant ist, was passiert, wenn Apple das weiter ausreift und es für ein Medizinprodukt zertifizieren lässt. Dann kannst du damit halt wieder anders rangehen. Also Medizinprodukte, die für den Einsatz wirklich genutzt werden können nach einer Diagnose, ist ja auch irgendwie noch mal vielleicht was Spannendes. Und sie haben so ein Research Kit, was Roddi eben auch angesprochen hat, schon rausgebracht. Also ich meine, das könnte dann so die Vorstufe sein. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich den Hesel geben wollen und ein Medizinprodukt sich in Europa zu zertifizieren. Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich denke, dass sie alles machen werden in dem Bereich, was irgendwie auch nur denkbar ist.
Das ist einer der, also allein in Amerika, wir haben ja vorhin schon gesprochen, dass Apple auch schon immer noch so domestic orientiert ist. Also mit ihren Retail-Geschichten. Aber die sind eben auch noch eine amerikanische Firma. Und das ist, diese amerikanische Health-Markt, na Medizin und wie nennt sich denn das, Gesundheitsmarkt, genau. Der ist wahnsinnig, da wird so viel Geld umgesetzt. Nicht umsonst kämpfen die da um ihre komische Gesundheitsreform. Das ist für die, glaube ich, das Wichtigste überhaupt. Und da sich als Anbieter einer allgemeinen Lebensvorsorge-Bereich sich zu etablieren und diese Verbindung zu diesen Gesundheitsstudien, also in diesen universitären Bereich mit reinzubekommen, plus dass man unter Umständen dann so quasi eine Art spezielle Apple-zertifizierte Medizin, Apparatemedizin mit der Technologie von Apple mit reinbringt, das kann sehr, sehr interessant werden für die. Und weil vielleicht habt ihr mich vorhin so ein bisschen missverstanden. Also ich finde diese Watch sehr, sehr wichtig und sehr, sehr gut, dass Apple es macht. Nur für mich persönlich ist es momentan ein Gerät, das für mich keinen so großen Nutzen hat, weil es einfach mal alles bei mir noch kompliziert. Ich habe dann irgendwie einen Laptop, ich habe ein iPad und ich habe ein iPhone. Und das ist für mich wirklich das vierte Rad am Wagen, dass ich dann auch noch irgendwie mitdenken müsste.
Und laden.
Ja, da haben sie ja schon, das ist ja gelöst. Das kann man ja schon mal ein bisschen spoilern.
Wie er nicht heißt leider.
Und ich aber also erst mal diesen, die sind als Fuß in der Tür in einem der lukrativsten Märkte, die vor allen Dingen mit dieser ganzen Babyboomer-Generation, die alle nicht so schnell sterben wollen und jetzt alle anfangen, irgendwie gesund zu leben, können die auf die nächsten 50 Jahre mit ihrer Nutzerschaft da. Für dich ist Apple schon existenziell seit vielen Jahrzehnten und für alle anderen wird es das jetzt werden. Und das ist ganz, ganz kluger Move. Und vor allen Dingen die Qualität ihres Designs und ihres UI und ihrer generellen Software ist halt besser als die der meisten anderen Medizinanbieter. Vorsicht, ich hab das gedrückt. Und den Schritt in diesen Vertrauensmarkt des klinischen Bereichs zu gehen, den könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass Apple das schafft. Und ja, auch das neue Apple Ring Center da, das könnte ja auch irgendwie so eine futuristische Klinik sein. Also diese medizinische Rundumversorgung, also nicht umsonst gibt es ja dieses Buch da, The Circle, das hat ja schließlich auch irgendwie diesen Apple Gedanken. Eine allumfassende Lebensvorsorge, was die SPD mal uns versprochen hat, dass Apple das jetzt... Es wird das Apple bringen. Ja, Apple löst das ein. Sozialstaat aller designt in Cupertino, California. Und dann kommt noch was anderes. Jetzt als Device könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es wirklich so ist, dass bestimmte Dinge einfach auf die Ambanduhr, auf das Display gelegt werden und man hat das Handy halt einfach in der Tasche. Das ist quasi wie so eine Art Personal Server. Ich hab das nicht mehr dauernd vor Ort, sondern bestimmte Informationen werden mir ständig so drauf... Das haben sie ja auch mal bei der Einführung der Apple Watch gezeigt, dass quasi die Störung innerhalb der normalen sozialen Interaktion über die Uhr ein bisschen subtiler funktioniert, als wenn Leute so entsprechend auf die Screens schauen, die dann ja auch ein bisschen größer werden und damit auch weniger... Also es wird alles ein bisschen aufwendiger, ein bisschen unhandlicher. Ich will es dabei haben, aber ich hole es nur noch dann raus, wenn ich ganz spezielle Dinge machen will. Wenn ich aber quasi so pushmäßig auf einem Laufenden sein will, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass einiges mehr und mehr über die Uhr passiert. Und jetzt spinne ich mal ein bisschen Science-Fiction-mäßig rum. Wer weiß denn, ob es nicht in fünf bis sieben Jahren schon erste holographische Projektionen gibt, dass auf dieser Uhr bestimmte Elemente dann dreidimensional animiert. Und dann haben sie quasi so ein Satellitenpaar. Ich nenne es jetzt einfach mal den Personal Server.
Das ist das, das ist jetzt von der dreidimensionalen Prinzessin Leia, die dich sozusagen in die Rettung des Universums anflät. Aber was du kriegst, ist ein dreidimensioneller Kackhaufen.
Der aber nett grins.
Alles vorstellbar. Wollen wir weiter in die nächste Produktkategorie gehen?
Kann ich noch mal ganz kurz in dieses Medizin-Ding reinpiksen? Also was für mich mal sehr interessant war, weil ich aber auch Medizin-Informatik studiert habe und was ich an Apple faszinierend fand, die haben eine Zeit lang wirklich damit geworben, was sie im Medizinbereich machen. Und ich habe danach nicht mehr so richtig viel gehört und fand das sehr, sehr schade, weil eben wie du auch gesagt hast, die ganze UI und so weiter, ist es halt doch teilweise viel leichter zu bedienen auch für Experten als so ein ranziges Windows. Und ich denke halt, dass das, was sie gerade bauen mit ihren, also auch einen Datenbestand aufbauen, nicht nur in dem Bereich jetzt von den Medizindaten, sondern vielleicht auch das, was jetzt vielleicht als nächstes Thema gleich kommt, die ganzen Algorithmen, was für die Bilderkennung ist, und die gesandt also in diese Schiene, die haben früher nämlich auch viel für Bild, Computer Vision und so geworben, dass das nämlich im Medizinbereich auch nochmal sehr interessant werden kann, wenn die da einfach gute Algorithmen haben. Das sollte man auch nicht vergessen.
Als es die bunten IMAX noch gab, waren die dann auf einmal auch überall in den Arztpraxen vertreten.
Stimmt.
Und da könnte ich mir vorstellen, das ist auch so eine bestimmte, ja so eine Arztpraxis muss clean. Also eigentlich sieht das alles schon so aus wie diese Apple Welt. So will man eigentlich in einer gut laufenden Praxis vom Design her, das muss so clean und weiß und wenn dir Johnny Hive irgendwie den Puls abnimmt, dann fühlst du dich ja in guten Händen.
Ich pack mal noch den Link zu dem Research Kit mit rein, falls es jemanden interessiert.
Zwei Sachen noch, wofür ich die Apple Watch brauche. Das eine ist der Kalender. Es zeigt mir immer den nächsten Termin an, den ich habe und vor allen Dingen wo er ist. Und das zweite ist der Timer, weil ich nämlich sonst immer meinen Tee vergesse. Das sind zwei Tabs auf die Uhr und schon ist der Timer auf drei Minuten gestellt und dann rappelt die irgendwann am Arm und dann hole ich den Tee raus und dann ist gut.
Das ist der erste Anwendungscase, der mich interessieren könnte.
Das benutze ich in der Tat auch oft. Die Wetter App wiederum ist so scheiße, dass ich nur hoffe, dass sie das jetzt mit der neuen Version wieder fixen, weil in der 2 war das perfekt und in der 3 ist es unbedutzbar.
Also mir fehlt noch die Killer App, die ist für mich quasi einkaufen.
Manchmal gucke ich noch, wann der Sonnenuntergang ist.
Oh ja, das gucke ich auch immer.
Oh, die Romantik.
Und das Party-Watch-Face, es gibt zwei Party-Watch-Faces. Das eine ist einfach nur so dünn und rot und nur die Zeit, damit es nicht groß auffällt.
Das ist die Kino- und Theater-Watch-Face.
Eigentlich ja, aber auch im Party-Kontext ganz gut zu gebrauchen, noch besser im Party-Kontext, also im Open-Air-Party-Kontext, ist halt da, wo der Sonnenverlauf angezeigt wird und man halt mal eben mit dem Rädchen so in die Zukunft gehen kann. Das Outdoor-Face. Weil dann kann man immer ganz gut timen, wann man denn endlich mal ins Zelt gehen will, wenn man noch ins Zelt gehen möchte, wenn es noch dunkel ist, damit man noch einsteht.
Das ist auch sehr praktisch.
Ja, das war vorher immer sehr schwierig vorherzusagen. Mit einer Apple Watch ist das perfekt.
Kannst du dir dann auch den Timer stellen, dass er dir genau sagt, eine Stunde hast du noch, solange es noch dunkel ist?
Nicht automatisch, aber das ist natürlich dann auch schnell gemacht. Da geht eine Menge.
Ja, also Apple Watch finde ich, auch hier wieder die üblichen Analysten und Apple-Hasser, was ist das? Das ist kein Erfolg und sie weisen ja gar nicht ihre Verkaufszahlen auf, offensichtlich ist es ein Misserfolg und so weiter und so fort. Ich finde es wichtig und richtig, dass sie das machen und ich glaube mittelfristig könnte das ähnlich wie beim iPod, dass es auch am Anfang nicht gleich der Gamechanger war, aber es war dann quasi so ein wichtiges Element, das dann mit der richtigen Software und mit der größeren Verbreitung von Internet dann sogar zu sowas geführt hat, wie diese Show.
Ja, sie sind auch jetzt schon weitergegangen als ich dachte. Also ich dachte ja, dass sie ein LTE-only-Device rausbringen. GSM wurde nicht erwähnt, aber 3G wurde erwähnt. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, ob sie nicht auch tatsächlich noch GSM-Calls auch noch mit unterstützen. Ich dachte so aus den Gründen heraus ist nicht. Und was man natürlich, was überhaupt, glaube ich, noch nirgendswo reflektiert wurde, es ist ja eigentlich nicht davon auszugehen, dass in dieser Apple Watch jetzt ein Teil dieses Chips von Qualcomm kommt. Apple baut doch hier sicherlich das erste Mal ihr eigenes Baseband ein.
Ja, aber wahrscheinlich haben sie IP eingekauft.
Das kann schon sein, aber damit haben sie dann sozusagen das erste Mal auch die Kontrolle über das Baseband. Das ist ihre Software.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen, ja.
Das ist natürlich auch ein Security Aspekt.
Nicht zuletzt, nachdem sie mit ihrem WLAN-Chip so fürchterlich auf die Nase gefallen sind. War das nicht ein Qualcomm, wo irgendwie das Baseband irgendwie weit offen war und plötzlich irgendwie ein Exploit für Android und für iOS funktioniert hat?
Das werden wir sicherlich die nächsten Tage sehen, wenn das Gerät dann draußen ist, dann werden wir irgendwie wissen, was Sache ist. Also hier wird im Chat angemerkt, es sei zumindest auf den Apple Webseiten wirklich nur von 3G und LTE die Rede.
Ja, das würde ich nicht so hochhängen.
Das heißt ja wiederum auch, dass wenn du in einem GSM, Edge, Land bist, dann keine Calls annehmen kannst.
Das würde ich nicht so hoch hängen, ehrlich gesagt. Es kann einfach sein, dass sie es nicht mehr dazuschreiben, weil sie es nicht mehr wichtig finden. Das kann natürlich auch sein, dass es zu viel Strom kostet.
Ja, natürlich kann das sein. Deswegen lassen sie auch 3G weg. Sie listen hier ja explizit die Frequenzen von LTE und UMTS. Das heißt, dass sie nicht GSM machen. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt hier auch wieder...
Das ist ja konsequent, dass sie mal technologische Schnitte machen.
Dann ist er ein abgeflattertes Federvieh.
Ja, wenn das jemand macht, dann Apple. Manchmal auch sehr schmerzhaft.
Edgeland ist abgebrannt.
Sehr schön.
Schluss mit Watch.
Apple TV, gleich weiter.
Ja, wir lassen uns mal kurz den TV einschmeißen. Ist ja auch nicht so spannend.
Naja, ich habe kein 4K-Abspielgerät. Insofern brauche ich auch keine 4K-Apple TV. Das wäre jetzt alles, was ich dazu zu sagen habe. Also ich hätte ja schon die andere Apple TV nicht gekauft, wenn ich sie nicht für einen Euro bekommen hätte. Also insofern ist die ganze Diskussion eben Mut.
Also ich habe ja, also in der Wohnung, in der ich wohne, befindet sich auch ein Fernseher. Ich würde ihn nicht unbedingt als mein Fernseher bezeichnen, aber er ist da. Und ab und zu benutze ich den auch.
Als Fernseher?
Auch. Ich benutze ihn auch, also ich benutze ihn selten und dann auch mal als Fernseher, aber das ist echt die Ausnahme. Also ich weiß nicht, ich gucke vielleicht so im Schnitt einmal im Monat kurz eine Minute Tagesschau, dann verfolge ich das Kinderprogramm, was dort geschaut wird.
Mit? Mit.
Und jetzt kriege ich mir mal überlegen, ob ich noch eine... Ach ja, genau, und Fußball schaue ich mir drauf an, wenn es da läuft und mich das interessiert. Also Live-Sport sozusagen. Wobei mich halt von den Live-Sportarten eigentlich nur eine interessiert. Und deswegen... Dafür ist das irgendwie ganz gut. Jetzt ist der aber hinüber, also der zerfällt förmlich so vor dem Auge. Und jetzt bin ich in dieser unangenehmen Situation, mir einen Fernseher aus dem Markt herauspulen zu müssen.
Bunte Lampe mit Bewegtbild.
Ja, und das ist wirklich haarig. Aber der Vorteil ist natürlich, dass man jetzt... Jetzt kauft man halt 4K. Jetzt kauft man 4K, dann hat man HDR, man hat all das, was eben auch das neue Apple TV dann auch unterstützen wird. Und ja, jetzt muss ich sozusagen nur noch mal gucken, vor welchem Hersteller ich am wenigsten Angst habe.
Na, die, die halt vor allen Dingen auch ein Dampptv anbieten, oder? Smart TV willst du ja nicht unbedingt haben.
Ja, aber die Damp... Also so richtig Damp... TV kriegst du eigentlich nicht. Du kriegst Displays, aber die haben dann wiederum keine Tuner drin. Dann könnte ich mir dann zwar noch mal ein Device kaufen, was das dann irgendwie hinten wieder reinschiebt und so weiter, aber so richtig fähige Fernsehtuner, die man irgendwie brauchbar benutzen kann.
Die gab's noch nie.
Die gab's mal vor 20 Jahren, hatte Sony mal so was auf dem Markt, aber das hat sich irgendwie nie durchgesetzt, weil es halt einfach immer mit den Funzeln selber kam. Und so modellar wollte sich das halt einfach keiner zusammenbauen, weil es halt auch wiederum keine Bildschirme gab. Heute kriegst du sowas, weil der ganze Signage-Bereich, da kriegst du also extrem große LCDs für echt wenig Preise. Also ich hatte ja das Thema hier auch schonmal angeschmissen. Kann ich ja vielleicht noch mal kurz hier nebenbei einwerfen. Es gibt so einen Hersteller zum Beispiel, der heißt SvedX. Scheint auch irgendwie aus Schweden zu kommen.
Meinst du?
Ja, ich meine, wenn die erste Sprache schwedisch ist, die hier irgendwie ist so. Und naja, dann hast du halt hier sowas wie 65 Zoll 4K LED-Monitor für 700, 800 Euro. So, das ist ein fettes Teil, aber da ist halt auch nicht viel drin. Macht aber halt 4K, macht 60 Hertz und du kannst halt da über HDMI deinen Rechner anschließen und dann hast du da einfach fettes Bild drauf. Weil so ein moderner Mac schmeißt halt einfach HDMI 2.0 raus und dann kannst du da auch die 4K mit 60 Hertz ansteuern. Das seht ihr natürlich jetzt alle nicht, in der Meterebene schauen wir gerade. Also wir sitzen am Tisch herum und auf der einen Seite des Tisches wirft ein Beamer an die Wand ein großes Bild. So groß könnte ich mir jetzt hier keinen Bildschirm hin. Also gibt es auch, aber ist mir dann zu teuer und irgendwie auch ein bisschen zu blöd. Da funktioniert der Beamer ganz gut.
Vor allen Dingen nicht in 4K. So ein 4K-Beamer, da wird es richtig teuer.
Ja leider, aber 4K-Bildschirme ist halt günstig. Na ja, Sweet X, aber hat dann wiederum keinen richtigen Tuner. Und diese anderen Dinger mit dem ganzen Smart-Klimpen, ganz ehrlich, da habe ich einfach so ein bisschen Angst, dass die mir geownet werden.
Eben deswegen sage ich ja, das will man nicht.
Da läuft halt so ein dusseliges Android, was wahrscheinlich dann irgendwie im halben Jahr keine Updates mehr kriegt. Oder noch schlimmer, es kriegt welche. Und dann, keine Ahnung, ich traue denen halt auch alles zu. Weil denen ist ja auch schon alles nachgewiesen worden, dass sie Klickverhalten und so weiter mal schön auf ihre Server pusten. Da kann man natürlich sagen, ja interessiert mich ja nicht, aber mich interessiert das natürlich schon. Wäre ja noch schöner. Vielleicht haben sie noch ein paar Mikrofone eingebaut. Da wird man dann doch schnell paranoid. Vielleicht hat ja jemand eine tolle Empfehlung für ein korrektes 50 Zoll Device, was so die wichtigen Features hat und was vor allem in der Usage nicht sackt.
Und warum holst du denn nicht einen Beamer für oben noch?
Ja, Beamer muss dann auch mal die Lichtverhältnisse in dem Raum haben.
Dann sagst du, Kids, wenn ihr ein richtig gutes Bild haben wollt, dann macht jetzt mal schön alles dunkel hier.
Ja, bring dann auch wieder Lautstärke mit rein. Und dann rutschen, aufhängen und noch mal ein Device und Kabel legen. Ist aus verschiedenen Gründen nicht die Option. Und wie gesagt, du kriegst dann auch nicht 4K. Und so 4K HDR finde ich schon geil. Also gerade für korrekt Film gucken, ist das ein Feature. Weil natürlich in so High-End Produktionen, da hast du dann eben auch diese Farbtiefe. Und dann ist das dann schon so ein bisschen Cinema. Schön teuer ist das neue Apple TV. 200 Euro wollen sie jetzt irgendwie für haben.
Naja, günstig war es nie. Vorher hat es immer 150 und 170 oder so gekostet.
Ja, und es war auch schon mal bei 69. Also es geht irgendwie.
Ja, aber nicht das mit SDK. Das war nie so günstig. Also das mit TVOS. Das hat schon immer 150 in der einfachsten Variante gekostet. Deswegen sage ich auch, ich hätte das nie gekauft, wenn ich es nicht zu dem günstigen Preis von einem Euro bekommen hätte. Weil, was soll das für dieses Kistchen da 150 auszugeben? Das ist so sinnlos.
Ja, die Frage ist, was ist halt deine primäre Einspielquelle für Content? Und klar, jetzt kann man sagen, jetzt kaufe ich mir Smart TV und wirke mich da mit diesen Build-in-Apps rum. Ja, ich meine, die kommen alle so mit Netflix Client on Board, aber wann wird der aktualisiert? Was bedeutet das Software Update auf den Geräten? Dann musst du da irgendwie ein Internetkabel oder W-Laden an dein Fernseher ranstecken, und dann ist das Ding irgendwie go-owned. Also ehrlich gesagt, das würde ich fast am liebsten irgendwie offline halten.
Ja, naja, ehrlich gesagt, ich habe halt immer wieder so bei Real oder so in der Grabbelkiste dann mal so Filme für Kinder gekauft, halt so DVDs. Da gibt es halt dann mal irgendwie alle Folgen Heidi oder so. Und dann hast du halt das Problem, dass du dann auf der Apple TV gucken willst. Dann musst du es entweder rippen oder aber du musst halt, du musst es mit dem VLC angucken und dann aber den Bildschirm vom Mac via Airplay auf die Apple TV mirron, weil es gibt keine von Apple vorgesehene Methode über Apple TV DVDs zu gucken. Das haben sie irgendwie aufgegeben. Na wie gesagt, du kannst halt, also wenn du den eingebauten DVD-Player nimmst, wo eingebaut? Den, der bei Mac OS dabei ist. Wenn du den nimmst, dann kannst du ja auch Fullscreen machen, aber dann kannst du keinen Airplay mehr machen, weil der dir ja verbietet, dass du den Content weiter, deswegen kannst du aber die DVD ganz normal auch mit einem VLC abspielen, kannst den Fullscreen machen und kannst dann ein Screen Mirroring per Airplay auf die Apple TV machen.
Ja, ich mein, das sagt eh alles. Eigentlich will man halt irgendwie so einen Server haben, wo die ganze Scheiße einfach drauf ist, aber dann kommt man auch gleich wieder in die Server-Administration rein und Filesysteme und Pipapo und Zugriff und hast nicht gesehen und Network Attached Storage mit Plex.
FreeBSD, my little server.
Fernsehen ist so was für Familienväter, oder?
Stimm ich dir zu.
Nee, ich guck ja nicht Fernsehen, mir ist das ja egal.
Fernsehen guck ich auch nicht, aber ich guck mir Filme an.
Ich auch eher selten, aber...
Also Fernsehen kann man sich auch nicht angucken.
Es sei denn, es läuft Arte.
Ja, okay, es gibt da Ausnahmen, aber die können die Klamorakas nicht.
Aber es gibt von Arte eine sehr gute Mediathek auf der Apple TV.
Ja, das stimmt.
Echt.
Es gibt eine gute Arte-Mediathek auf der Apple TV.
Ich hätt das Apple TV immer nie an, weil ich halt auch nicht so derjenige bin, der sich vor diesem Fernseher setzt.
Ich brauch da kein Live-Fernsehen. Die ARD-Mediathek ist brauchbar, die ZDF-Mediathek gibt's irgendwie auch eine, ist brauchbar. Die ARD-Mediathek ist brauchbar, also ich weiß nicht, wie ich mit dem Fernsehen, ne? Also irgendwie...
Ich guck total viel Fernsehen, aber halt über Satu auf meinem Rechner. Aber wie gesagt, sehr, sehr spezial. Also bei mir gibt's gar kein Fernsehen eben als technisches System mehr, aber ich gucke trotzdem gerne lineares Fernsehen, so als...
Gibt's denn Satu eigentlich auch auf Apple TV, ja, ne?
Das weiß ich nicht, das hab ich noch nie gesehen, da drüben.
Also bei mir ist es einfach ein Tab im Browser und, ja und, kann ich ja dazu mal sagen, das ist noch etwas, weswegen ich eigentlich noch einen Laptop habe, weil das ist quasi mein Fernseher. Und das Programm von Satu, das guck ich mir auf der, zum iPad an, damit ich weiß, was ich dann klicken kann. Klar, man könnte jetzt vielleicht noch eine Fernbedienung, aber wenn ich dann ach, dann kann ich wechseln, dann wechsle ich dann händisch manuell, nehme ich mich vor zum Rechnerbeuge, um dann quasi einen neuen Kanal einzuschalten. Und das ist natürlich keine, das ist nur in einem Single-Haushalt möglich oder vielleicht bei Netflix und Chill als Möglichkeit, aber für mich funktioniert das dadurch sehr, sehr gut. Und vor allen Dingen, ich kann den Deckel zumachen und es gibt keinen Screen in meinem Wohnbereich. Ich will keine Geräte haben. Also das einzige Gerät, was dort erkennbar ist, ist mein alter Synthesizer. Und das ist halt schwer analog. Und ich will einfach nichts mehr, ich will keine Geräte mehr, ich will, dass alles verschwindet. Und...
Zahlt sie für Satu?
Ja, ich glaube, 5 Euro im Monat oder so was.
Ist das dieses Premium oder ist das das Normale?
Es gibt einen Free, da kriegst du nur die öffentlich-rechtliche Grundversorgung.
Und noch ein paar andere.
Und dann gibt es eins, das hab ich für 5, und dann hab ich irgendwie 50 Kanäle oder sowas. Ob das schon Premium ist?
Nee, Premium ist eben 10 Euro pro Monat oder 100 pro Jahr.
Gibt's dazwischen noch was?
Weiß ich gerade gar nicht.
Na dann mal gucken, was bin ich denn?
Ich seh hier nur Free und klar, Leute, macht doch mal eure Webseiten mal so, dass man irgendwie gleich weiß, was Sache ist. Furchtbar. Also gibt's auf Apple TV, im Übrigen gibt's auf allen Devices, und dann kann man also irgendwie normales Fernsehen dann irgendwie auch noch reinziehen. Das ist ja auch noch eine Alternative, wenn das zufällig funktioniert. Funktioniert das zufällig?
Ja, also wirklich, ich hatte mal einen anderen Anbieter, mit dieser Umstellung von, wie hieß denn dieses, hab ich schon vergessen, diesen Stick DVB-T2, was dann sich abgemeldet hat, hab ich noch mal einen anderen Anbieter probiert, und der war nicht in der Lage, überhaupt einen Stream ruckelfrei zu liefern, und Satu ist wirklich, bis auf ein paar Hick Ups, die mal am Tag passieren, so zwei, drei, sehr vernünftig.
Und das ist jetzt Streaming live?
Ja, das ist wirklich wie Fernsehen.
Ah, okay.
Nur, dass ich halt jetzt keine Fernbedienung habe, wahrscheinlich gäbe es das vielleicht sogar, weiß ich nicht, ob man quasi einen Browser mit einer Fernbedienung bedienen kann.
Browser, Webbrowser, nein.
Also, das ist halt der Nachteil. Ich muss jetzt wirklich ans Gerät, muss da...
Ja, an Apple TV würde dir das weiterhelfen.
Aber dann bräuchte ich halt auch einen Screen. So habe ich ja einfach das Ding nur auf meinem Laptop. Und wenn ich Fernsehen ausmache, kille ich den Browser und deckele zu.
Ich bin auch ein Fan von wenig Devices im Haushalt.
Aber es ist klar, das ist nicht skalierbar über anderthalb Leute hinaus.
Es gibt hier wohl noch so einen anderen Anbieter, Maschinen, habe ich auch noch nie gehört. Na ja, also The Race is on für das beste Vice.
Jetzt bin ich aber beruhigt.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob Apple TV am Ende irgendeinen Erfolg einfahren wird. Irgendwie ist das auch alles noch ein bisschen blöd. Aber das ist jetzt irgendwie den ganzen alten HD-Content, den man sich vielleicht geschoppt hat, dann auch gleich als 4K gepflegt schon mal ganz ordentlich. Na ja, sehr viel mehr können wir nicht sagen. Falls jemand noch einen guten Tipp hat, irgendwie, für Fernsehtipps bin ich empfänglich. Dieser Markt ist auch undurchdringbar. Ich hab auch versucht, in diesen Suchportalen irgendwie mal so mich durchzuklicken. Da gibt's ja so auf guides-heils.de, da gibt's mal so wirklich so eine nerd-kompatible Suche. Problem ist nur, die Suche kann noch so geil sein, wenn die Datenbasis nicht stimmt, kommt da auch nur Müll bei raus. Ich hab dann halt diverse Fernseher gefunden, die sehr wohl in meine Suchkriterien reinfielen, die da aber nicht richtig getaggt waren und dann stehst du irgendwie auch bekloppt da.
Das ist alles furchtbar. So, iPhone.
Das gibt's mal, das ist 8, oder? Ich meine, das ist doch, das ist doch Legacy.
Ja, it's more of the same.
Sprich zu jemandem, der noch nicht mal auf 6 gegangen ist.
Weil ich auf den richtig heißen Scheiß warte.
Es ist irgendwie halt fast alles SE Nutze.
Ich mach mein X bei iPhone X.
Ich bin mit dir im Boot.
Das einzige wahre Telefon. Wenn ihr seine Tastatur hättet, wäre es noch toller. Weißt du eigentlich, wie deprimierend das ist? Da ist man auch nicht mal 30 und stellt fest, es wird kein Telefon mehr geben, was mir wahrscheinlich gefallen wird, weil alle gehen von den Tastaturen weg.
Ja, so geht es mir gerade mit den Laptops.
Dann bau dir doch eins.
Stimmt dich genau von den Tastaturen weg.
Kannst du das als Aufgabe an deine Studierenden mal stellen?
Ja, designen wir dann eins, aber bauen muss ich trotzdem selber.
Ja, aber vielleicht gibt es ja auch so ein 3D-Printer-Workshop.
Könnt ihr meinen Blackberry auseinandernehmen?
Du hast doch Real Artistship.
Genau, du baust den Blackberry in Bluetooth-Tastatur für dein iPhone.
Das wäre super cool.
Das wäre auf jeden Fall ein Hackprojekt.
Also mir hat das iPhone 8 ein bisschen Leid getan und mir hat auch der Präsenter, wie heißt der Mann?
Phil Schiller.
Phil Schiller ein bisschen Leid getan.
Und der tut mir schon seit Jahrzehnten Leid.
Weil er das mit gebremsten Schaum präsentieren musste und wurde er von der Bühne geschickt um dann nach ein paar Minuten wieder aufzutauchen und dann zu sagen, hallo ich bin's. Ich hab jetzt wirklich heißen Scheiß dabei. Das war schon nicht einfach.
Ist irgendwas falsch an dem iPhone 8?
Das einzige was falsch ist am iPhone 8, dass es einen iPhone X gibt.
Naja, das setzt ja voraus, dass das iPhone X in derselben Liga spielt und auch genauso erstrebenswert ist.
Ich finde das iPhone 8 so als Extension von dem iPhone 7 jetzt nicht verkehrt. Abgesehen davon, dass es wahrscheinlich wieder keinen echten Button hat. Ich hab ab und zu in der Firma zum Testen mal so ein iPhone 7 in der Hand. Und dass der Button da unten nichts tut, sondern nur so tut, als würde er was tun, das geht mir tierisch auf den Sack.
Das ist eine reine Wirkung. Ich glaube immer noch, dass das die bessere Lösung ist.
Ja, aber du hast das halt auch noch nicht so oft in der Hand gehabt, glaube ich. Also ich, nein, nein. Also bei dem Trackpad, ja, bei dem eingebauten Trackpad auch, aber dieser Button da unten, vor allen Dingen das Gemeine an dem Button ist, sobald das Telefon aus ist, du drückst da drauf, dann tut sich halt nichts mehr. Das ist halt das, ne, also ich hab halt, also wir haben da so einen Schrank, da sind jetzt viele Devices drin und ab und zu prüfe ich mal nach, ob die auch alle ordnungsgemäß ausgeschaltet wurden. Wie macht man das? Man drückt bei allen auf den Homebutton und das macht halt überall klick, klick, klick, klick, klick, klick, klick, klick, und dann hast du, also nicht mal richtig, weil es gibt auch nicht wirklich nach.
Da kennst du ja auch nicht, ob es eingeschaltet war, von daher ist es ja eh.
Doch, weil es wird hell.
Ja, es wird ja auch bei dem anderen auch hell, auch wenn es nicht klickt.
Ja, aber es klickt ja gar nicht erst.
Wieso?
Weil es aus ist und dann ist die Taptic Engine nicht an. Dann hast du so einen richtigen Brick. Also man spricht ja sonst schon von einem Phone, was nichts tut als einen Brick, aber bei dem ist es noch brickiger, weil nicht mal mehr die Buttons was tun.
Das ist mir jetzt zu romantisch.
Das mag sein, aber so viel Romantik muss sein.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, das iPhone 8 kommt halt im klassischen Lama-Design seit dem iPhone 6 irgendwie. Ich finde, das sieht halt immer noch scheiße aus.
Sie haben jetzt ein anderes Gold, das sieht ganz hübsch aus.
Ja, ein anderes Gold.
Da ich ja dieses Goldtelefon habe, stehe ich ja mittlerweile doch sehr darauf. Also sie haben glaube ich jetzt eine andere Farbe.
Ja, sie haben das zumindest hervorgehoben, dass es da jetzt so ein Gold-Aluminium gäbe.
Ja, es sieht schön warm aus, also es ist eine sehr schöne Farbe. Und dieses hässliche Pink haben sie endlich mal rausgenommen.
Und dass man das Wireless Chargen kann. Gut, wir haben immer über die Android-Leute gelächelt, die das ganz super toll finden. Wahrscheinlich ist es auch cool, wenn man da laden kann. Ich weiß es nicht, also irgendwie.
Naja, das ist eine gute Frage. Also Wireless Charging finde ich ja, also für den Namen finde ich ja schonmal falsch.
Weil, ist ja nicht so, ne?
Ist ja nicht so, dass du keinen Wire bräuchtest.
Ja, schon, aber jetzt...
Der steckt halt nur nicht in deinem Telefon.
Ja, aber... Das ist so, als würdest du sagen, Wifi ist nicht wireless, weil du musst an dem Access Point auch ein Kabel haben. Also das ist jetzt irgendwie Unsinn. Entschuldigung.
Meinetwegen, aber wie auch immer. Ich könnte es zum Beispiel im Schlafzimmer nicht benutzen, weil ich natürlich mein Telefon verwende im Bett.
Ja, aber weißt du, wenn du dir so einen IKEA Nachtkasten kaufst, wo so ein QI-Lade-Ding drin ist, dann packst du es da halt auf die richtige Stelle und dann wird es geladen.
Dein Problem ist, dass du also keinen Nachtisch hier hast.
Doch, ich hab eins.
Ist mir so egal, wie das heißt.
Aber dann nutzt du die Timer-Funktion nicht von Overcast oder jeder anderen Podcast-App. Ansonsten ist es doch total convenient, einfach das Telefon wegzulegen. Achso, du meinst mit Benutzen nicht Podcast hören zum Einschlafen?
Ich höre den Podcast und konsumiere Informationen.
Ja, und? Was hat das jetzt mit dem Kabel zu tun?
Ja, wenn es Kabel drin ist, lädt es halt. Zum iPhone SE kann man sogar laden und noch einen Kopfhörer reinstecken.
Das kann man bei dem 6S auch immer noch.
Das geht zwar mit den AirPods jetzt eigentlich auch viel besser, aber da ich ja meine Ladenschale verloren habe, bin ich da derzeit leider ausgeschlossen.
Es gibt doch jetzt die Wireless-Ladeschale für die AirPods.
Ich habe eine prinzipielle Frage. Ist es eigentlich klug gewesen, eine Kategorie iPhone 8 zu entwickeln? Oder hätte man es nicht einfach ein Update fürs iPhone 7 machen können und hätte es einfach so belassen? Mir tut das ein bisschen leid, dass quasi ein iPhone mit einer neuen Ordinalzahl immer ein großer Schritt gewesen ist im Apple-iPhone-Universum.
Nein, das stimmt so nicht.
Doch, es war meistens sein Schritt.
Face-Change heißt es.
Genau, aber das ist ja kein Face-Change.
Die großen Schritte waren meistens von Nummer zu Nummer S waren technologisch die Schritte größer. 5S hat deutlich mehr gebracht als das 5 gegenüber dem 4S. Das 4S war der größere Fortschritt usw. Mit Ausnahmen, aber im Wesentlichen kann man das so nicht sagen. Die haben mit der Zahl etwas Sichtbares verbunden. Das heißt, wenn sich das äußere Design nennenswert verändert hat, das hat es jetzt. Deswegen ist es nachvollziehbar, dass sie auf 8 gehen.
Ich habe mich mit dem 7 so wenig beschäftigt, dass ich überhaupt nicht erkennen kann, ob mit dem 8 da was...
Es ist halt innen Alu und die Dinger haben hinten Glas.
Stimmt.
Jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen, ist hinten überhaupt relevant, aber so ist es nochmal.
Also, ich sehe das Dilemma. Einerseits wollten sie etwas Tolles rausbringen, wirklich so ein Leuchtturmprojekt wie das iPhone X. Ob das gelungen ist, darüber können wir gleich nochmal sprechen. Aber damit wird dieses iPhone 8 eigentlich zerrieben. Und das finde ich ein bisschen aus der…
Was meinst du jetzt zerrieben? Von seinem potenziellen Markterfolg her oder nur von seiner emotionalen Wahrnehmung?
Von der emotionalen Wahrnehmung und von seinem Novelty-Charakter. Also du kannst einfach als Neuerung nicht bestehen gegenüber dem iPhone X, weil wenn das iPhone… Ich nenne das jetzt einfach mal iPhone X, weil ich finde das viel geiler, ja, so zu nennen. Wenn das jetzt 3000 Euro kosten würde und was weiß ich, dass irgendwelche Keramik super gebürstet… Hier werden Zeichen, hier sind noch stumme Kommunikationsabläufe, die könnt ihr gar nicht so richtig abschätzen, aber die haben jetzt meine Konzentration gestört. Also ich finde ein iPhone, das 800 Euro kostet, so in der Luxusausstattung, und eins, das jetzt 1100, also in Deutschland 1100 kostet, also der Unterschied ist mir nicht zu...
Das 8 Plus, da geht es bei 900 los.
Also ich finde den Unterschied zwischen iPhone 8 und iPhone 10 dann wiederum nicht so groß, als dass ich gesagt hätte, Mensch, lasst uns doch lieber das iPhone komplett neu machen. Und es gibt nur dieses eine und das ist iPhone 10. Und ich weiß ja, warum sie es nicht machen wollten, weil sie es in der Masse nicht produzieren können, wie sie es brauchen, um ihren bisherigen gewohnten Markterfolg zu halten. Und deswegen ist es eigentlich ein Lückenfüller. Und das finde ich problematisch. Ich glaube, dass man das nicht anders hat lösen können, aber ich finde es trotzdem problematisch und lässt mich ein bisschen unbefriedigt zurück.
Hättest du es gerne als iPhone 7S gehabt?
Ich habe überhaupt, ich will mich jetzt nicht.
Oder findest du es überhaupt dämlich, dass sie einen iPhone 8 rausgebracht haben?
Ja, das denke ich auch.
Ja, oder der Zeitpunkt selten vielleicht im Sommer, ein Special Event, ich weiß es nicht. Ich finde es jetzt unglücklich gelaufen.
Also ich finde es nicht so schlimm, das wird schon seine Käufer finden. Ob das jetzt so der Brüller wird?
Das wird genau dieselben Käufer finden, die es vorher auch gefunden haben. Das iPhone X werden einfach neue Käufer sein. Weil unten, ich meine, das Line-Up ist ja auch, dass sie mittlerweile verkaufen das SE. Das geht jetzt, glaube ich, was, weil 300 Euro los.
6, 7, 8, X. 5, Baureihen.
Sie covern damit sozusagen so viel in den Markt, dass sie jetzt sehr tief in das Midrange-Segment reingehen, wo sie so bisher noch gar nicht präsent waren. Das wird ihnen schon mal eine ganze Menge Freunde machen. Also auch das SE scheint ja ein ziemlicher Erfolg zu sein, trotz allem. So, und auf der anderen Seite machen sie mit dem X nach oben jetzt nochmal eine komplett neue Produktkategorie auf, nämlich so High-End Formel 1 Telefon. Im Gegensatz zu dem iPhone 8 können sie halt in dem iPhone X Dinge verbauen, die es noch nicht in 70 Millionen Stückzahlen pro Jahr gibt.
Das finde ich das Coole, weil das ist das, was das iPhone vor zehn Jahren war. Du warst mit so einem iPhone in der Hand, wie so ein kompletter Außerirdischer. Das wird man jetzt nicht mehr machen können. Aber trotzdem ist es einfach mal so ein Step Ahead. Das finde ich schon gut und richtig. Und dann finde ich es auch dafür jetzt auch nicht so teuer. Das sind die 200, 300. Dann muss man halt nicht jedes zweite Jahr sich ein iPhone kaufen. Dann kann man das halt mal drei oder vier Jahre benutzen. Dann spielt sich das nicht mehr.
Ja, wie lange der Spaß jetzt so gehen wird, also ich wäre noch nicht mal überrascht, wenn wir nächstes Jahr noch ein iPhone 9 sehen würden. Oder ein 8S.
So ein 8, nee, da könnten sie ja jetzt nichts. Bis zum Ende melken. Das ist ein 8S, ein 9 und ein 9S und darüber die X-Welt.
Da gibt es immer das X und da gibt es auch nur eins. Und das ist immer The Hottest Shit. Da bauen sie immer den krassesten Prozessor rein. Da bauen sie immer den Holy Obi-Wan. Ja genau, da geht es richtig zur Sache. Wobei ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen überfragt bin, haben sie eigentlich jetzt denselben Prozessor drin? In beiden? Also exakt denselben?
Ja, wenn ich das recht in Erinnerung hatte, ja.
Nicht, dass wir da jetzt Quatsch erzählen, aber ich glaube auch.
Als ob uns das abhalten würde.
Worauf ich hinaus will, ist die Prozessorleistung. Also dass das ja sozusagen auch ein Argument ist, dass du unter Umständen dort einen Prozessor verbaust, den du noch gar nicht in den Stückzahlen bauen kannst, wie du es eben in den normalen High-End oder Midrange iPhones einbaust.
Danach sahst du aber nicht aus.
Nee, so sehe ich es auch gerade.
Sie haben da den Bionic-Chip mit der neuronalen Architektur drin. Ja, ich habe eins gesehen, aber ohne Vergleichszahlen. Deswegen waren die Zahlen nicht so aussagekräftig. Interessant finde ich aber ehrlich gesagt eher, was sich hinter der neuronalen Architektur verbirgt. Also das ist, glaube ich, auch mehr als nur ein bisschen Grafikchip.
Okay, wollen wir jetzt erstmal über den Prozessor reden?
Ja, wenn du da Infos hast.
Ja, na gut, also wovon wir überhaupt reden, ist der A11 mit dem schicken Bionic-Dingsy Zusatz. Und ich habe Geekbench 4 Scores gesehen, wo das Ding einen Geekbench-Score von über 4000 Single-Core und ungefähr 10.000 Multi-Core hat. So, natürlich ist es erstmal eine Zahl, die keinem was sagt. So, setzen wir das jetzt mal in den Kontext. Das Ding ist so schnell wie ein MacBook Pro 13 Zoll.
Single-Core, nicht Multi-Core.
Das Ding ist schneller als mein nachgerüsteter Mac Pro, wo ich jetzt irgendwie den fettesten oder fast den fettesten Prozessor reingebaut habe, den man da überhaupt nachrüsten kann. Ich bin jetzt irgendwo so bei, ich glaube, 3000 angekommen. Und ich gucke gerade nochmal genau, was meine Zahl ist. 2827 kriege ich mit meinen zwei Xeon-Prozessoren. Und der eine Stein im Telefon macht einfach mal 4000. Das Ding ist ein Brüller. Vor allem, wenn du dir mal die Geekbench-Scores anschaut von den ganzen Android-Devices, die so auf dem Markt sind. Die haben halt die Hälfte. Also die Performance ist beyond. Und sie haben jetzt außerdem noch eine eigene GPU gebaut. Das heißt, da sind sie jetzt auch ihren Dienstleister losgeworden. Sie sind jetzt in der GPU-Business sozusagen, auch wenn sie das natürlich jetzt nicht an Dritte verkaufen. Aber auch da haben sie sich jetzt quasi gelöst.
Hatten sie das nicht vorher schon mal irgendwann?
Nicht immer, nein.
Doch, ich glaube schon. Oder hatten sie da auch nur IP eingekauft und sie selber auf dem Chip beraten?
Ja, klar. Sie haben das schon auf ihrem SoC integriert. Das ist kein externer Stein. Aber das GPU-Design, ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wo jetzt die Übergangskante ist, ist alles von dieser britischen GPU-Bude gewesen, die ja jetzt gerade irgendwie Warnmeldungen rausgeben müssten und sich zum Verkauf angeboten haben, weil Apple halt gekündigt hat. Apple hat gesagt, wir kaufen nicht mehr bei euch. Und jetzt sehen wir da halt sozusagen das Ergebnis. Die haben also jetzt mit ihrer Silicone-Abteilung, ihrer Silicium-Abteilung quasi die nächste Bastion gestürmt. Nicht nur, dass sie jetzt die mit Abstand schnellsten Mobilprozessoren bauen. Jetzt gehen sie halt auch im GPU-Bereich, wobei ich da jetzt keine Benchmarks bisher gesehen habe, mit. Und natürlich dann auch dieser Bionic-Anteil, also diese, wie haben sie das genannt, Neural Engine. Im Prinzip ist das nichts anderes als eine optimierte Vektor-Unit zum Durchrechnen von Machine-Learning-Codes. Einfach ein hochoptimierter...
Ja, so neuronale Netze rechnen.
Genau, womit sie halt diese Gesichtserkennung...
Wo ist denn... Damit bewegt sich Apple ja eigentlich ganz gegen den Strich des normalen, verteilten, also arbeitsteiligen Prozesskapitalismus. Dass du quasi möglichst deine Fertigungstiefe verringerst und gleichzeitig einfach überall Sachen einkaufst bei Spezialisten und du setzt deine Marke drauf und machst das große Geld. Gibt es da irgendwelche, weiß man da schon genaueres? Wovon jetzt genau? Was der tiefere Sinn dahinter ist, ist quasi dieses Spezial-Expertentum.
Genau das, was wir vorhin in dem Geschichtsteil auch schon besprochen haben. Apple möchte gerne die Hardware, die sie mit ihrer Software bespielen, zu 100 Prozent unter ihrer Fuchtel haben. Sie wollen jeden Aspekt davon machen, weil sie kennen ja die Anwendung. Sie kaufen sich nicht irgendeinen Stein aus, der irgendwie generisch für in etwa die allgemeinen Bedürfnisse einer kompletten Marktsituation ist. Sie wollen einen Stein haben, der exakt genau auf dieses eine Device und nicht mehr und nicht weniger gemünzt ist.
Aber das könnten sie ja mit ihrer Einkaufsmacht ihrem Lieferanten auch genauso aufochtrühen. Sie müssten das ja nicht mit Mann und Maus selber inhouse machen.
Ja, aber wenn sie sowieso schon so spezifiziert etwas nur für sich machen lassen, warum sollen sie das nicht gleich unter ihrer Ägide machen? Da gehen die hin und bieten den Entwicklern Salern, sagen hier, arbeitet mit uns und tschüss.
Interessant, das heißt, ich definiere ein Lastenheft, das ist so ausgefuchst, dass es sinnvoll ist, es gleich selber zu bauen.
Ja genau, im Prinzip formulieren sie über mehrere Jahre dann die Ausstiegsklauseln, damit sie den Laden übernehmen können. Also das Einzige, was ich nicht gekauft hab und nicht kaufen wird, wahrscheinlich ist Arm.
Du hast halt auch das Ding, dass sie jetzt in der Lage sind, einen Prozessor zu bauen für sich, für die iPhones, den niemand anders hat, weil niemand ist in der Lage, den gleichen Prozessor zu bauen.
Der Hintergrund ist, gibt's vielleicht, sind da auch Security Aspekte dahinter, dass sie sagen, wir wollen uns zum Beispiel vom chinesischen Totalitarismus möglicherweise befreien. Wir wollen die genaue, wir wollen wissen, was wirklich auf den Bare Metal, welches Elektron da hin und her geschoben wird und nicht, dass die NSA zum Beispiel das...
Deswegen haben die aufgehört, Custom eingekaufte Computer in ihren Serverfarm zu verbauen. Die bauen sie jetzt auch selber, weil die halt Backdoors da gefunden oder zumindest vermutet haben.
Okay, und da fühlen sie sich sicherer, weil bevor jetzt die NSA kommt mit so einem, wie heißt das immer, National Security Letter, das ist quasi ein anderer Prozess, das ist der offizielle, dem können sie nicht ausweichen, das sei denn, sie gehen offshore. Aber zumindest die Backdoors schließen sie, das ist quasi Fair Game. Du kannst nicht belangt werden, weil du einfach ein sicheres Schloss baust, dafür wirst du auch in Amerika nicht verhaftet, dass niemand knacken kann.
Ich will jetzt nicht so viele Verschwörungstheorien aufspinnen, warum sie das jetzt auch noch machen können. Ich meine schlicht und ergreifend dieses, wir haben unsere Hardware komplett unter Kontrolle und wir designen die Componenten dieser Devices genau auf die unmittelbaren konkreten Bedürfnisse dieser Devices, ist halt einfach auch aus Stromerspannsgründen, da muss man schon gar nicht mehr weiter diskutieren. Sicherheit kommt da noch mit rein, hatten wir ja eben schon das Ding mit dem Baseband. Wie gesagt, mich würde es nicht wundern, ich weiß es aber nicht, mich würde es aber jetzt nicht wundern, wenn sie das jetzt in der Apple Watch gemacht haben, würde es mich jetzt nicht wundern, wenn das iPhone 8 und iPhone X auch gar keinen Qualcomm Baseband-Ship mehr hat. Die gehen ja mit denen gerade richtig krass zur Sache und wenn sie es jetzt noch nicht draußen haben, dann haben sie es in der nächsten Generation nicht mehr.
Darf ich da kurz einen Haken schlagen?
Ob's aller Art, einen Haken schlagen.
Ich hab da gerade gesehen, der Chip, der die Satellitenordnung macht, kann jetzt nicht nur GPS und GLONASS, sondern auch Galileo. Zumindest jetzt hier in dem X oder 10. Steht hier.
Interessant.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist 8 da auch, aber...
Wo steht das?
Auf der Seite technische Daten ganz unten. Ah, dann gucken wir mal bei dem 8. Da gibt es noch einen weiteren Dings, der mir jetzt nichts gesagt hat. Warte mal, wo ist es denn jetzt hier? Ist doch nicht ganz unten. Boah, ist das eine lange Liste.
Tatsächlich, das ist 8 auch. Das ist jetzt GPS, GLONASS...
Und QZSS, was auch immer das ist, wahrscheinlich chinesisch.
Quasi-zenite Satellitensystem.
Russland.
Ein im Aufbau befindliches japanisches Satellitensystem.
Oh, ein Japanisches.
Ein japanisches.
Die Japaner machen das auch. Nee, Russen, das ist GLONASS.
GLONASS ist Russisch.
Das klingt natürlich auch schon so.
Global Nierdandosara Systema irgendwas.
Ach, das ist ja interessant.
Aber ich will noch mal eine Lanze brechen, wie unglaublich agil, intellektuell dieses Management ist, weil der große Erfolg von den letzten zehn Jahren war ja, dass sie quasi wirklich gesagt haben, designt bei Apple in Cupertino und dann alles ausgelagert haben und wirklich ganz, ganz ausgetüftelte Outsourcing-Prozesse gestartet haben und dass sie jetzt seit einigen Jahren dasselbe Management, es schafft, aus welchen externen oder internen Überlegungen heraus quasi jetzt wieder ein Insourcing zu betreiben, das ist selten. Normalerweise hast du so One-Trick Ponies im Management. Die kommen irgendwie von der Uni und haben gerade gelernt, Harvard Business Letter sagt, alles Outsourcing oder alles Insourcing und dann machen die das eine Generation und sterben, wenn sich der Wind dreht. Und dass innerhalb so kurzer Zeit so eine große bedeutende Firma, nach Marktkapitalisierung unter Umständen die wertvollste überhaupt, so agil ist, quasi so ein Supertanker, innerhalb relativ kurzer Zeit umzuwerfen, finde ich sehr bemerkenswert.
Das ist halt einfach nicht deren Blues irgendwie. Also Apple ist ja auch wahrscheinlich die einzige Firma in den ganzen Fortune 500, die keine externen Berater beschäftigt. Also sagen sie, es stimmt nicht ganz. Natürlich haben sie einzelne schon Experten, holen sie sich ran. Aber die haben nicht so Beraterunternehmen, die da reinkommen, so Unternehmensberater. Wir analysieren sie doch mal hier unsere Abteilung und schlagen sie uns mal vor, wen wir entlassen sollen. So wie bei, sag schon. Du kennst Office Space oder nicht?
Leid, aber ich kenn, es gibt ja andere Berater-Shows, zum Beispiel House of Lies. Da ist es ja quasi noch mal ins Extrem getrieben.
Wir haben uns jetzt einen Termin, wir kauen uns mal zusammen Office Space an. Weil es geht nicht. Wenn ihr den Film nicht kennt, dann ist das jetzt das nächste, was ihr tut. Office Space anschauen, weil der ist lustig. Alles, was man über IT und Business wählt und das Leben in der Neuzeit, im Vergleich zu Companies wissen muss. Der Chat ist sofort dabei. Ich kenne auch kaum einen Film, der so einen hohen Quotingquotienten hat. Es gibt so viele epische Momente in diesem Film, die alle für sich genommen vollkommen zitierfähig und lustig sind. Da kann sonst nur der Anhalter mithalten. Das Outsourcing und das Insourcing, das ist ja so ein bisschen eine Religion bei Apple. Auch diese interne Apple University, die Steve Jobs noch auf die Schienen gesetzt hat, kurz bevor er dann verschienen ist. Das lehrt ja sozusagen die Angestellten bei Apple the Apple Way. Das heißt, selbst wenn die von irgendwelchen Ausbildungszentren kommen, dann werden die erst mal unlearned und kriegen dann sozusagen... Ja, genau, so ein bisschen wie bei... Wer ist noch gleich dieser Alien-Film, die Black Man, nee, die Men in Black, wo dann so der Stift vor die Nase gehalten wird und so vergessen. Geblitz-Dingst.
Genau, so Flash und... This is not the iPhone X.
So, und jetzt erzählen wir dir mal alles. Gut, dann nehmen wir uns nochmal das X nochmal genauer vor. Also ich muss ja sagen...
Du warst underwhelmed. Ich habe so ein Tweet von dir gelesen. Gestern, rausgehauen.
Welches Tweet hast du da gelesen?
Also ich hoffe, dass sie das SE noch lange bauen.
Ja, das hoffe ich.
Ja, das klang in dem Kontext, dass gerade so eine Ultramaschine dort vorgestellt worden ist, so ein bisschen mekelig.
Ja.
Ich finde das auch ganz komisch, Tim. Also ich fand auch mein Highlight war dieses Animoji auf jeden Fall. Das ist so bisher das Einzige, wo ich sage, wo das Ding war.
Wo ich fast gebrüllt habe und abgefeiert habe, war, wo Johnny Ive von Alloy und Aluminium sprach. Aluminium. Aluminium sprach. Aluminium ist die amerikanische. Aluminium sprach und dann durch ein sprechendes Einhorn ersetzt wurde.
Das hatte schon wirklich eine ganze Menge Humorvalue, das stimmt.
Da dachte ich mal so, ja.
Mein Favourite, den Zusammenhang war dann Great Federidi als Huhn.
Ja, der ist ja richtig abgegangen.
Der ist sich auch für nichts zu schade. Das ist eigentlich das Schöne an ihm.
Das war wirklich ein Moment fast von Authentizität. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie lange sie das geprobt haben, aber es fühlte sich zum ersten Mal an, als würde dort so etwas wie ein echtes menschliches Wesen hinter die Spule hervorscheinen und nicht so ein Sales- und Keynote-Droid, der da ferngesteuert, entsprechend gebrieft und auf Beta-Blockern auf die Bühne geschoben wird.
Aber das iPhone X, das müssen wir mal sagen. Also mal ehrlich, diese komische Akten- ordnerstanze da, also da oben so diese Aussparung zum Abheften, das jetzt irgendwie so, als ist alles aus einem Guss zu verkaufen und dann schält sich so der Bildschirm da so rum. Ich meine, was ja lustig ist, ist, dass sie ja quasi jetzt wieder an den Ursprung des Macintoshes 1984 zurückgegangen sind, weil jetzt gibt's auf einmal wieder rounded Corners.
Ja okay, die waren vorher ja nicht rounded wirklich. Also sie wurden ja nur per Software abgerounded.
Auf Mac? Ja klar, aber design-wise sind sie da, jetzt sind sie halt richtig rounded Corners. Und ja, keine Ahnung, wie das so laufen soll.
Ich muss dazu Folgendes sagen.
Hast du dir schon angeschaut, wie das so programmatisch läuft? Die haben noch da so ein Developer-Video.
Ja, nee, das noch nicht. Ich hab mir heute einfach als allererstes jetzt den Xcode GM Golden Master runtergeladen und die eigene App mal auf dem Simulator laufen lassen. Und jetzt muss ich, ich muss mal hier jetzt irgendwie so ein, so ein, so ein Ding so schnell machen, um euch das zu zeigen. Und da kann man natürlich auch das, das iPhone X auswählen als, als Dinge, worauf das laufen soll. Und das macht aber Sinn. Also wenn man da Software drauf laufen sieht, dann ist es plötzlich nicht mehr so schmerzhaft. Weil du hast halt rechts und links in den beiden Öhrchen, hast du halt die bisherige Statusbar und der Rest, der fügt sich so relativ organisch. Also auch wenn du unten eine Tabbar hast, wo du zwischen einzelnen Screens wechselst, dann passt die halt auch schön in die Rundung rein und so weiter. Das ist gar nicht so schlimm, wie man erst denkt. Deswegen hab da so ein bisschen meinen Frieden mitgeschlossen, das in Aktion zu sehen. Am Anfang dachte ich auch so, oh je, das ist aber hässlich. Aber also ich finde die Rückseite mit dem Wulst, mit dem Kamerawulst deutlich hässlich.
Na gut, das haben wir jetzt schon seit Jahren.
Ja, aber der ist ja noch mal größer geworden und jetzt hochkant und also...
Wie groß ist das Ding eigentlich?
Das ist einen kleinen Tick kleiner als das Plus, glaube ich.
Es ist, nee, das ist nicht genau die Größe von dem normalen. Ach nee, stimmt, das ist nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das ist dazwischen.
Wie das ist noch größer als das...
Nein, es ist so groß wie das Plus. Also das Display von dem X ist ziemlich genauso groß wie das Display vom Plus.
Nein, wie groß ist das Gerät?
Ja, sag ich ja. Das Display ist so groß wie das Display vom anderen, deswegen fehlt ein bisschen was an dem Plus und deswegen ist es ein bisschen kleiner.
Aber es ist noch größer als das......als das nicht Plus... .derzeit wie der normale iPhone.
Aber also vom Bild sieht es minimal nur größer aus.
Gott, das ist ja noch größer.
Also, ja gut, man sieht jetzt hier für nicht viel, aber du hast halt hier in den beiden Örchern...
Niemand sieht jetzt überhaupt irgendwas.
Roddi zeigt uns gerade die Entwicklungsumgebung.
Ja, ich habe hier ein leeres Projekt aufgemacht. Du hast halt in einem Örchen die Uhrzeit, in einem anderen Örchen hast du die Batterie und den Wi-Fi-Kaffeefilter und die Balken.
Ja, das habe ich alles gesehen. Für mich ist ja entscheidend, wie groß ist dieses Telefon.
Ja, habe ich ja gerade beschrieben.
Es ist noch größer als das iPhone, sozusagen, als das iPhone 8.
Ja, also es dürfte hier jetzt ungefähr...
Ist das so groß da, oder?
Es dürfte jetzt ungefähr Originalgröße haben.
Sicher?
Auf deinem Bildschirm? Nein. Never.
Na, kein Fall.
Vielleicht ein bisschen kleiner.
Also es sieht wirklich aus wie ein Ziegelstein sonst.
Ja, das kann nicht sein.
Also es ist irgendwo zwischen dem Plus und dem Nicht-Plus.
Hast du da einen Zoom drin?
Ja, man kann... Ja, nein, das dürfte jetzt nicht gezoomt sein, aber man kann im neuen... Man kann im neuen Simulator die Größe stufenlos verstellen, warum auch immer.
Und du kannst nicht sagen Originalgröße?
Doch, das kann ich im Prinzip tun, nur die Retinaauflösung von diesem Mac ist natürlich nicht gleich der Retinaauflösung.
Hallo, wir verlieren uns ein bisschen.
Keiner kann das nachvollziehen, was ihr gerade sagt.
Wir haben zuweich noch gar nicht über ARKit gesprochen. Und wenn so ein neues...
Wenn es denen nicht passt, verlieren sie uns. Aber die beiden sind die ganze Zeit schon am sich verlieren.
Nein, mir ging es um die Größe.
Ich wollte sagen, es ging um die Größe.
Ja, aber so ein Fenster in diese Mixed Virtual Augmented Reality braucht ja auch eine gewisse Größe. Und du siehst, die Menschen wollen quasi dieses Fenster in diese neue Welt nutzen. Und das kann nicht mehr auf diesem Mäusekino-Screen von einem iPhone SE stattfinden.
Ja, aber VA kannst du auch auf dem iPad machen.
Nein, ich nehme doch nicht mein iPad irgendwo mit.
VR kannst du da auch nicht drauf machen.
Also AR, wie auch immer. Ja, nein, aber er hat sich ja gerade beschwert.
Das ist ein Flohzirkus.
Er hat sich ja gerade beschwert, dass es zu klein ist.
Ja, du willst es größer haben und das ist auch toll so. Und das geht nicht anders.
Ich will es erst mal in der Hand haben, aber mich reizt das alles nur sehr eingeschränkt, solange mein Telefon schnell genug ist.
Ich muss sagen auch, also das iPhone 8 zum Beispiel reizt mich jetzt sehr, sehr begrenzt nur. Also aber das X, warum denn nicht? Also es sieht halt nicht aus. Und was ich über den Simulator ganz interessant fand, dass das Ding keinen Homebutton hat, sondern dass man tatsächlich die App so wegwischt von unten raus, das ist gar nicht so problematisch. Also das kann man schon machen, das ist irgendwie nicht so wild.
Kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen. Lass uns aber den Elefanten im Raum reden. Naja, Face ID, weil ich meine, das ist ja sozusagen wesentlich die Änderung. Ich habe mich an Touch ID, fand ich ja super. Da war ich am Anfang auch ein bisschen zögerlich, ich darf das ja auch, ich bin ja alt. Und Face ID habe ich noch nicht so richtig alles durchdacht, glaube ich, was so für Aspekte da jetzt so mit reinkommen. Gehen wir mal davon aus, es funktioniert gut. Was das sozusagen bedeutet, dass man so Unlocking damit macht. Schaut man immer auf sein Telefon, wenn man es unlockt? Ja, vielleicht auch, keine Ahnung.
90 Prozent der Fälle, aber nicht immer.
Du wirst es lernen.
Ja, ist es dann ein Problem, es dann doch zu tun?
Naja, sagen wir mal so, wenn ich das Telefon unlocke, dann weil ich mit ihm interagieren will. Und das Interagieren, das tue ich meistens dadurch, dass ich auf den Screen gucke und weiß, wo das User Interface Element ist, wo ich als nächstes drauf tappe.
Ja, aber ich gucke zum Beispiel auch auf dem Screen, wenn ich in meinem Stuhl zurückgelehnt sitze und das Ding liegt auf dem Tisch und ich anlocke das und dann schaue ich einfach schräg drauf und das Telefon kann mich gar nicht sehen. Das ist dann etwas, was ich nicht machen kann. Ich muss mich vorbeugen und es anlocken oder es muss es anheben. Aber ich kann nicht schräg drauf schauen. Das ist vielleicht auch ein non-issue.
Daran habe ich noch gar nicht gedacht.
Wir versuchen nur, darüber nachzudenken, was das für Implikationen hat, nachdem Touch-Idea eigentlich eine tolle Idee war.
Und der biometrische Skandal war ja schon genau so da. Also ob jetzt nur ein Face-Signal oder Fingerabdruck, die Problematik ändert sich aus meiner Sicht jetzt nicht. Biometrie bleibt Biometrie. Entweder man findet das schlimm oder man versucht damit zu leben. Und dann kann ich mit beiden Systemen leben, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich frage mich vor allem, wie sie, sie sprechen ja von einer deutlich geringeren Verwechslungsrate. Ich frage mich erstmal, was ist eigentlich mit Zwillingen?
Das können sie nicht, das steht extra drin.
Zwillingen, das war auch so was.
Einige Zwillinge können sie nicht unterscheiden. Einige, zwei. Also es ist die logische Konsequenz, wenn beide Zwillinge jetzt ein iPhone haben, macht euch ein Name ins Gesicht.
Das weiß ich nicht, weil dafür haben sie ja ihre komische neuronale Super Learning Engine vielleicht. Also wir können ja schon, wenn wir ein bisschen engeren Kontakt mit Zwillingen haben, sie unterscheiden auf verschiedenen sensorischen Ebenen.
Eineigige?
Hast du eineigige Zwillinge als Freunde?
Nein, aber ich hatte in der Stufe, nicht in meiner Klasse, in der Stufe hatte ich eineigige Zwillinge und die waren auch, nicht nur weil sie sich dann auch individualisiert haben, also unterschiedliche Kleidung, sondern es war erkennbar gleich, aber doch anders. Same, same, but different und das hat sich dann auch, ich wusste immer, wer von den beiden das ist, was nicht heißt, dass der eine sich vielleicht hätte mal verkleiden können für den anderen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das hätte durchhalten können.
Also ich habe welche in der Klasse gehört, man hat sie nur unterscheiden können durch einen Leberfleck im Gesicht. Das ist dann der glückliche Zufall, den musst du aber dann auch immer sehen. Also ich habe die häufig mit einem falschen Namen angesprochen.
Aber ein Leberfleck würde das iPhone wahrscheinlich nicht unterscheiden, ne?
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher. Das kann Tiefensensoren sein. Wenn das nicht nur ein Leberfleck ist, sondern nicht jeder Leberfleck ist ja flach.
Vielleicht gibt es noch eine geheime, freizuschaltende Twin Detection Novel Tactical Engine, die du dann quasi so Hotspots machen kannst. Und dann guck immer mal auf diesen Bereich.
Oder du musst immer mit deinem Zwilling gegen lernen. Das jetzt nicht, und das bin jetzt ich, das ist er, das ist ich, das ist er.
Die sind dann quasi miteinander verbunden und machen das, das könnte schon möglich sein.
Ich kenne Zwillinge, da habe ich massiv Probleme, die auseinanderzuhalten. Die kann man eigentlich nur daran auseinanderhalten, dass der eine ein bisschen forscher ist und der andere ein bisschen schüchterner. Aber so vom reinen Aussehen her habe ich massiv Probleme. Also die haben sich auch nicht so, wie du es nanntest, individualisiert, sondern die sind irgendwie wie so ein Ehepaar unterwegs immer.
So oder so, Apple macht da ein Big Bad auf, irgendwie wir brauchen kein Touch ID mehr und verzichten da einfach mal komplett drauf. Und deswegen machen wir das jetzt damit. Und die Technik finde ich ganz interessant. Es ist ja schon einige Jahre her, dass Apple mal die Bude gekauft hat, die ursprünglich mal die ursprüngliche Entwicklung gemacht, die später dann zur Kinect führte. Und da war das nur Software?
Ja, und die Hardware, die Sensoren genauso.
Genau, da haben wir alle gerätselt, wozu könnte denn das gut sein?
Jetzt wissen wir das.
Die bauen das ins Telefon ein. Ich glaube immer, wenn jetzt Apple irgendwas kauft, gehe ich mal davon aus, dass sie das in sechs Jahren ins Telefon einbauen.
Wenn sie nicht noch irgendein sonstiges Out-of-the-Air-Produkt ausbuddeln, von dem wir keine Ahnung haben, was es sein wird, aber ja.
Aber was ein bisschen spooky ist, ist doch eigentlich, dass jetzt die Kamera immer an ist, oder? Von der wir sonst sie immer abkleben. Weil jetzt wissen sie nicht nur eine Kamera, es ist eine Infrarotkamera, es ist eine Dingsmungskamera, es sind da sechs verschiedene Sensorik-Elemente wurden doch in der Show, in der Präsentation aufgestellt. Insbesondere hat sich jetzt gezeigt, dass sie immer an ist, sonst würde ja die Emoji, die Emoji-Geschichte nicht funktionieren.
Wie groß soll dann bitte dieser Klebestacker dann mit der Schiebe, mit dem Schiebeteil werden?
Musst du nach oben abklappen, sonst hast du ja dein Öhrchen verdreht.
Ja, ja, so ein kleines Loch geht nicht mehr, da muss die ganze Sensor-Leiste, die da drauf ist, da ist ja echt so einiges drauf. Ich hab's mir jetzt gar nicht aufgeschrieben, was da alles ist, aber einerseits halt dieser Infrarot-Projektor, der Abstandssensor halt, der schon immer da war, die Kamera natürlich, zwei Kameras, weil das ist ja jetzt auch Portrait-Mode.
Das gibt irgendein komisches Dot-Teil, haben sie das genannt, wo sind diese Punkte?
Das ist aber ein Projektor.
Ah, okay.
Der Infrarot-Punkte projiziert und die Infrarot-Kamera sieht die Rückstrahlung. Genau, und macht daraus ein 3D-Abbild.
Das ist ja das Prinzip der Kinect. Damit macht sie ja überhaupt dieses 3D-Ding. Und dann können sie halt in Echtzeit da ein 3D-Modell draus berechnen und das vergleichen sie halt. Und ich denke, das, was sie da auch demonstriert haben, dass eine Maske von deinem Gesicht nicht greift, ist einfach schlicht, dass die Maske halt dann keine Variation im Gesicht hat, weil in dem Moment, wo du halt auch nur ein bisschen irgendeine Bewegung machst...
Also wenn es eine Infrarot-Kamera ist, dann kann die eventuell auch Wärme...
Ja, die auch noch wärmer unterscheiden kann.
Und wenn du eine Latex-Maske im Gesicht hast, dann ist die auf Zimmertemperatur, dann ist die nicht warm.
Ich haue aus meinem Chat rein, dass was bei MacRumors drin war, zeigt, was drin ist.
Ja, das hatten sie in der Präsentation.
Genau, da war noch ein Lautsprecher und ein Mikrofon an der Stelle fand ich auch ein bisschen komisch, dass ein Mikrofon an der Stelle ist.
Die haben nicht nur zwei Mikrofone.
Oder drei sogar.
Es gibt drei oder vier. Ich weiß nur, weil ich jemanden kenne, der sich rausgebaut hat und dann dransteht und yay, du kannst mich nicht mehr hören.
Doch.
Sie haben halt so viele, um dieses ganze Noise-Cancellation und irgendwie Richtungsgeschichten da zu machen, das scheint ja auch ganz gut zu funktionieren.
Was ist denn der Flood-Illuminator? Ist das auch noch mal Infrarot, Flutlicht?
Oder was ist das?
Haben sie einen Forward-Flash? Wurde nicht erwähnt, ne?
Ja, das heißt, damit machen sie beleuchten vielleicht generell mit Infrarot und machen dann noch mal mit den Dots, noch mal die Dots drauf, in einer anderen Intensität? Ist auf jeden Fall alles ganz schön.
Also es ist ein Riesenaufwand und ich würde fast sagen, die Authentifizierung ist nur so ein Beiprodukt dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Das würde ich nicht sagen. Also dadurch, dass sie jetzt keinen Fingerprint-Sensor mehr drin haben, ist das schon auch ein zentrales Ding.
Okay, es war für sie mit der, sie hätten noch eine weitere Punkt.
Ich glaube die Animojis waren die Seiten. Das Beiprodukt? Das Beiprodukt, ja.
Das würde ich auch sagen. Und dazu kommt ja noch, dass sie halt auch noch so ein komplettes Kit haben, um sozusagen Gesichtserkennung auch für Apps bereitzustellen. An der Stelle wird es natürlich dann ganz interessant, weil du natürlich jetzt problemlos Face-Scanner-Apps rausbringen kannst. Und die kannst du natürlich jedem Menschen irgendwie vor die Nase halten und dann kannst du natürlich schon wirklich Biometrie klauen ohne Ende. Also das wird schon so ein bisschen zur Massenbiometrisierung führen hintenrum. Das könnte ich mir definitiv als Risiko vorstellen, so für die kommende Zeit. Aber das war ja auch absehbar. Da werden wir irgendwie so richtig nicht drum rumkommen, denke ich mal. Selbst wenn sie halt jetzt das eigene Bild da in die Secure Enclave reinpacken, heißt das nicht, dass es mit anderen Bildern auch so ist. Aber ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie das Interface ist. Dieses ganze AR-Thema, das hypen sie ja irgendwie enorm. Man muss sagen, ja, so teilweise gehe ich da mit. Teilweise halte ich das für noch ein bisschen sehr aufgeblasen. Viel von dem, was man derzeit so sieht, ist halt eigentlich eher Dönekens. Aber sie haben zwei, drei Beispiele genannt in der Kino, die ich nachvollziehbar fand. Also zum Beispiel diese Nachthimmel Beobachtung mit so Informationssuperimposing. Du hast ja derzeit so schon diese NightSky Apps, wo du hochhältst und dann siehst du ja eigentlich auch das Kamerabild. Und dann haben sie aber nur quasi die Kompass und Gyro-Ausrichtung, die in etwa das dann an die richtige Stelle macht. Jetzt können sie mit diesem AR die tatsächlichen Sterne sehen, matchen und genau einfach nur noch ein Textlabel an den Sternen heranschreiben und genau da, wo der Stern auch ist, sozusagen noch mal eine Lichtverstärkung draufsetzen. Sprich, diese Anwendungen werden vermutlich super akkurat werden. Und natürlich das Deiche auch so mit Flight Tracker, siehst ein Flugzeug am Himmel, dass du dann eben auch genau sagen kannst, hier ist das Flugzeug genau an der Stelle und das handelt sich dabei um.
Ich sehe auch momentan eher noch, dass es so eine Spielerei ist. Mir fehlt noch gerade so diese Killer Application, die vielleicht so ganz banal vor aller Augen, und es wird so ein Furzkissen 3.0 und dann haben wir auf einmal gemerkt, ah, AR funktioniert.
Taschenlampen-Apps.
Irgendwas, was...
Schilder übersetzen. Du bist in Japan und willst wissen, was auf so einem Ding draufsteht und dann schaust du durch dein Telefon drauf und siehst halt alles auf Deutsch oder Englisch.
Ja und da ist es eben halt nur diese Brückentechnologie, weil eigentlich will ich das direkt im Auge haben, ich will nicht diese komische Zwischenebene, dass ich mein Telefon dazwischen habe. Weil auch diese komische Game Simulation war doch ein bisschen komisch, mit denen wurde ich da so auf einem Tisch. Habt ihr das verstanden? Das war für mich keine gute Spielerfahrung, weil ich hatte gedacht, dass man vielleicht einen echten Tisch, also wie hier der Tisch in der Meta-App, da steht eine Menge Giraffel rum. Und ich dachte, das wäre jetzt quasi...
Keine interne.
Giraffel.
Giraffel League.
Und man könnte jetzt den Tisch so wie er ist, als so eine Shooter-Engine, dass man halt so kleine, also quasi virtuelle kleine Spielzeugsoldaten hat, die sich gegenseitig bekämpfen, aber die jetzt hier zwischen den beiden Controllern langlaufen. Und das hätte ich cool gefunden, dass du quasi das Bild nimmst, dann hätte ich gedacht, dass quasi dann auch noch abgescannt wird, quasi die entsprechende dreidimensionale Daten mit dem Foto und dass man quasi instantan, weißt du, wie Kinder in der Sandgrube, du baust dir schnell quasi eine Map und lässt dann quasi mit dem AR-Kit und dem Spiel kannst du quasi in dem von dir gebauten Kinderzimmerlandscape als Level dann deine Figuren. Das hätte ich cool gefunden, aber auf einem leeren Tisch vor einem Millionen oder Publikum, der eine, ich stehe jetzt so auf und mache unbeholfene Bewegungen, das war einfach lächerlich.
In Positionen, die man einfach unmöglich freiwillig länger als zwei Minuten auch nur aushalten möchte, das fand ich auch hochgradig peinlich.
Ich glaube, das ist auch so ein bisschen der Situation geschuldet, dass du natürlich willst, dass so eine Demo in so einer Keynote auch funktioniert, also wirst du dir die maximal optimale Situation für die Demo aussuchen. Diese Tische, die sie da immer haben, die haben auch immer sehr deutlich erkennbares Holzmuster, sodass der ganze Algorithmus dann sehr schön und sehr exakt tracken kann, wo ist denn jetzt eigentlich der Tisch im Raum, dass das so dann wahrscheinlich kein großer Erfolg wird. Das weiß ich nicht. Also ich kann es mir auch nicht so richtig vorstellen, dass es das bringt, aber hey.
Ich denke, das erste, was wir sehen werden, sind vor allem Experimente mit dem speziellen API für die Gesichtserkennung. Also es ist ja nicht nur das normale AR Kit, sondern da gibt es ja noch mal so eine Sonderform, speziell nur Face Recognition. Und ich meine, das ist natürlich interessant, weil du kannst jetzt auf einmal dein ganzes Gesicht benutzen, um User Interface zu bauen. Du kannst mit der Nase rümpfen, ja, und dann kriegst du einen neuen Vorschlag für ein Logo, das irgendwie random generiert wird. Und wenn du lächelst, dann merkt er sofort so, okay, das könnte dir gefallen haben. Wenn du halt so guckst, dann kannst du instantan quasi die Reaktion als soziale Bewertung machen.
Deswegen meinte ich, dass die...
Dass du gleich die Sterne auf YouTube mitverfeilen.
Genau, das wollte ich... Das wollte ich damit sagen, dass vielleicht die Authentifizierung nicht das Wichtigste ist, sondern dass ich quasi so eine Art Reaction Engine habe, dass ich schaue ein Video und kann quasi...
Werbungsauswertung...
.und kann gewissermaßen über meine Mimik quasi die Emotionalität direkt in irgendeiner Art Kommentar... Also jedenfalls, ich kann direkt das Feedback zurückgeben. Und wenn ich das freischalte... Als Animoji... .wird das in irgendeiner Form... Ja, kann ja quasi unter Umständen sogar als Animation unter dem Video quasi laufen, die gesamte Zeit über, wie ich die Nase rümpfe, wie ich drüber lache, wie ich gelangweilt bin. Übrigens hatte ich auch das Gefühl, als sie Snapchat mit reingebracht haben, ob das vielleicht ein Punkt ist, um Snapchat wieder...
Was war denn das nochmal für eine Demo?
Das waren letztlich die...
Als Federighi diese Maske, dieses Gezeugnis, hatte er aufs Gesicht was drauf.
Also dass man quasi diese Technologie für Snapchat freischaltet und denen da quasi neue Möglichkeiten bietet. Also da hab ich so gedacht, oh, das könnte aber für Snapchat eine sehr, sehr wohlfeile Demo gewesen sein.
Allerdings, vor allem wenn das halt so mit Sharing verbunden ist, mit cool aussehen und so, so was funktioniert natürlich bei den jungen Hüpfern.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass da viel, viel mehr dahinter ist, als einfach nur auf sein Telefon zu gucken und dann schaltet sich der Bildschirm frei. Das wollte ich damit sagen.
Für die Generation Emojis, das ist ja wirklich gut.
Ich betateste gerade so eine kleine App, die irgendwie einen einmal am Tag fragt, wie man sich fühlt. Die könnte man im Prinzip auf dem Level... Die sollte einfach nur so gucken, sie ist aber irgendwie ganz schön deprimiert aus.
Oder aber sie wertet die gesamte, also wenn es wirklich die gesamte Zeit aufnimmt, sie wertet einfach den gesamten Tag aus und sagte dann...
Mein Twitter-Client könnte sozusagen für jeden Tweet abspeichern, wie ich dazu geguckt habe. Und dann brauche ich keine Favoriten mehr zu markieren, sondern sehe ich das sozusagen wie so ein Thermobild irgendwie. Hier hast du gelacht, hier hast du mit dem Kopf geschüttelt. Oh wow, ey, das ist...
Also ich meine, Mimik zwischen Menschen ist ja nur ein ganz wichtiger Level von Kommunikation, also von Teilbereich von Körpersprache. Und der kann relativ kompetent über dieses System mit integriert werden. Vielleicht entwickeln sich da Dinge, die weit über das hinausgehen, was die da angekündigt haben bisher. Aber was ich ein bisschen spooky finde, ist, dass die ständig mitläuft. Und da... weiß ich nicht, könnte ich mir vorstellen...
Wahrscheinlich nicht, weil das braucht ja Strom. Also wenn du diese Raise your iPhone-Geste machst, wo es angeht, dann wird sicherlich auch die entsprechende Face ID...
Ja, das macht er nicht die ganze Zeit.
Dinge angehen und sobald du eingeloggt bist, sag ich jetzt mal, sobald es angeloggt hat, wird der Kram auch wieder ausgehen. Weil... also... Du hast halt keine Kontrolle darüber. Also wenn du jetzt normalerweise die Front-Facing-Kamera anmachst, dann siehst du das halt, dass die an ist. Also zumindest bei Mac.
Ja, aber so als Bewertungsding, so dass man sagen kann, ich tapp irgendwo drauf. Und solange ich rechts unten da auf die Ecke drücke, geht so mein Emo-Recorder an. Und was auch immer gerade im Kontext ist, mache ich einfach in dem Moment so ein Bewertungsgesicht.
Plus noch, wenn ich mich quasi verschalte mit der Apple Watch und die meinen Blutdruck gleichzeitig zu dem Zeitpunkt noch irgendwie mit abgreifen. Plus die Pulsfrequenz und das noch gegenseitig matchen.
Jetzt geht's los.
Ich hab 200 Puls.
Das müsste doch das Richtige für Tinder sein.
Das Vibe war gestern. Potenzial, das Olle X. Ja, da ist viel drin. Sonst hätten wir das auch nicht so ausgespielt mit diesen Karikaturen, mit den Animojis.
Mir hat ein Elefant gefehlt, aber vielleicht gibt es da mehr Tiere, als man da so gesehen hat in der Übersicht.
Ein Elefant, den Emojis? Aber ich denke, das wird jetzt die nächsten Jahre das Thema sein.
Ich mag noch mal Elefanten.
Bis sie wirklich auch noch das letzte Emoji noch animojiert haben. Alles, was irgendwie Augen hat und beidreinigt auf den Bäumen, das wird jetzt von Apple einmal dreidimensional durchgenudelt.
Kriegst du doch noch deine Layer.
Was könnten wir denn jetzt da noch wünschen für ein Emoji, was irgendwie noch, dass sie den Kacke auf den Deich genommen haben, das fand ich eigentlich schon, weil das wäre die erste Forderung gewesen.
Jaja, genau, das haben die gleich abgeräumt.
Das ist doch trefferversenkt, oder?
Ja, was gibt es denn noch für ein Emoji?
Ich meine Einhorn gibt es auch, Kackhaufen und Einhorn ist doch eigentlich schon alles, was man braucht, oder?
Katze gibt es aber auch.
Und der Hund mit den Schlapperohren.
Ich könnte mir aber auch zum Beispiel so ein Disney-Kit vorstellen mit Donald Duck und solchen Figuren, die man halt als Lizenzelement einspeist.
Na ja gut, für die Uhr gibt es ja schon das Zifferblatt mit Mickey Mouse und Minnie Mouse. Leider gibt es nicht Donald aus irgendeinem Grund. Es gibt nur Mickey und Minnie.
Wenn man vom Pixel redet, die Lampe, diese Lampe, die ist...
Also, most popular emojis in der Emojipedia, wobei ich jetzt nicht weiß, was die Popularität jetzt hier ausdrückt, aber das steht so auf der Homepage und das nehme ich jetzt einfach mal.
Wie populär ist eigentlich die Emojipedia?
Keine Ahnung, aber wenn man mal was über Emojis wissen will, ist die Emojipedia schon ganz brauchbar. Also, most popular is person shrugging.
Ist das hier dieses, was man auch so aus Faski machen kann?
Aber es gab dieses klassische Smiley, gab es gar nicht. Es gab nur irgendwelche Tiere und so, aber einfach nur diese normale Kopfköte, irgendwie den...
Was ich ja eigentlich auch noch gut fände an diesen Emojis. Normale Kopfköpfe.
Habt ihr das gesehen, did someone say an Emoji, was gleich da oben in der Dingspedia drauf ist?
Was ich eigentlich ganz cool fände, wäre, wenn die Hand noch dabei wäre, dass man so ein Face Palm oder hier Thinking Face...
Handerkennung sozusagen. Dass man auch die Hand auch noch...
Just Thinking Face, so hm? Die Hand. Ja, da ist ja...
Das wäre auch nochmal ein schöner... Also, dass man nicht nur ein Gesichtscanner hat, sondern auch nochmal ein Handscanner hat, dass man sozusagen so mit der Hand... Allgängigen, bekannten... Darüber kann man dann gleich das passende Emoji sozusagen auch aussuchen. Das wäre natürlich auch noch so ein Emoji, du guckst einfach, du guckst wie das Emoji... Also, du guckst irgendwie und dann wird dir ein Emoji vorgeschlagen, was so guckt, wie du da gerade guckst. Das wäre vielleicht auch noch ganz praktisch. Extra Bonuspunkte, wenn er das dann noch auf echte Ascii... Ascii-Smiley-Emojikons umsetzen kann. Gibt es hier noch? Monkeys hatten sie auch, ne? Catface, Dogface, Lionface, Tigerface, Horseface, Pigface, die haben die ganzen Face-Emojis, haben sie quasi abgeräumt. Maus gibt es noch, Hamster, Rabbit, ich glaube, das ist das nächste, was wir sehen. Panda haben sie auch, ne?
Panda haben sie.
Bär, Frog wäre noch zu haben gewesen.
Aber es gab jetzt einen Hinweis, und zwar diese... Wie heißt denn... Die haben doch ein Logo entwickelt für diese Gesichtserkennungssoftware, oder für diese... Und... Das ist das gute alte Macintosh.
Das hat mich auch daran erinnert, ja.
Ja, und es ist wirklich... Wenn man das alte Pixel-Icon über das Neue legt, dann merkt man, das ist einfach das Echte, das Unverpixelte, das Eigentliche. Und das finde ich auch wieder mal wie so ein... Wie sich dieser Kreis schließt, weil dieser lächelnde Macintosh, das war doch das, was für jeden, also für mich als Nicht-Computer-Mensch, der dieses komische Code, wenn der so linebasierte irgendwelche Experten, da irgendwas reingehackt haben, das war ja für mich Geheimwissenschaft, aber dass dieser Computer angegangen ist und der lächelt mich erstmal an, das war einfach so eine vertrauenserweckende und mir auch zutrauen einflößende Geste. Und ich finde das spannend, dass sie jetzt eigentlich mit dieser Geschichte wieder auch in diese Anfänge zurückkehren. Und wirklich diese Mensch-Maschinen-Schnittstelle intuitiver zu machen als bisher möglich.
Du meinst jetzt mit Face ID oder mit dem Logo von Face ID?
Ja, generell auch jetzt mit den aus Face ID abgeleiteten Animojis, dass es jetzt nicht ein Gimmick ist, der jetzt aufgesetzt ist. Ich würde fast sagen, das ist tief in der Apple. Also dieser sprechende Kackhaufen ist tief in der Apple DNA verankert.
Zumindest kann man jetzt auf so vielen Ebenen weiter denken. Da würde die ausnahmsweise mal 100 Prozent der Hörerschaft zustimmen.
Zumindest ist es tief in der DNA von Apple aus einem sprechenden Kackhaufen noch ein niedliches Feature zu machen. Also es hätte man durchaus übler hinkriegen können. Ja, in der deutschen Übersetzung heißt es das Flatt-Dings da, was wir vorhin hatten, Infrarotbeleuchter.
Okay, dann ist es genau das. Also es gibt sozusagen eine Szenenbeleuchtung und dazu nochmal das Raster dazu.
Der Punktprojektor.
Das heißt, die machen aber auch hell im Dunkeln, damit sie quasi, weil die Kamera wird ja auch Infrarot, also selbstverständlich kann sie Infrarot sehen, weil sonst könnte sie ja auch dieses Raster nicht sehen.
Sonst wäre sie keine Infrarotkamera.
Also mal gibt es noch mal eine separate Infrarotkamera.
Ja, ganz rechts.
Wenn es wirklich die Technologie von der Kinect ist, dann könnte das so aussehen.
Ja, ich frage mich jetzt nur gerade, wenn das beleuchtet wird, dann könnte ja auch die normale Kamera auch noch was sehen, weil die ja auch Infrarotlicht auch sieht.
Ja, aber die neueren Apple-Kameras können das alle nicht mehr. Ja, ziemlich. Also ich weiß von diesen 6S, dass die normale Kamera, die sieht kein Infrarot mehr.
Also das heißt, normalerweise haben sie es weggefiltert, aber das können sie ja dann auch in Software wegfiltern, was sie vielleicht nicht machen wollen, keine Ahnung.
Das glaube ich nicht. Das glaube ich nicht. Also früher gab es ja immer diesen Trick, man nimmt eine Handykamera, um zu gucken, ob das Infrarot-Fernbedienungs-Ding sie was sendet, wenn es nicht funktioniert, weil dann sieht man nämlich die Infrarot-Diode da blinken in dem Kamerabild. Und es geht mit den neueren Phones geht es halt nicht mehr. Also es geht mit der Front-Facing geht es noch, aber mit der hinteren Kamera geht es nicht mehr.
Es heißt ja auch so, normale Kamera, das würde man sowas haben, einfach aus Qualitätsgründen, damit das nicht stört, aber die Infrarot-Kamera wiederum würde das natürlich dann auch sehen. Gut, es ist auf jeden Fall komplizierter Kram. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie sehr sich das so schlagen wird, weil gerade bei diesen ganzen optischen Sachen, ich meine man sieht das ja bei Samsung, die haben ja auch Gesichtserkennung auch schon mal eingebaut, da reicht dann halt ein Foto und so, ja hurra, ganz toll. Das wird natürlich hier nicht reichen.
Also es war schon cool, dass sie auch noch diese Hollywood Special Effects Studios noch mit eingebunden haben, mit den Masken und dass sie das zumindest behauptet haben, dass mal so Mission Impossible, Tom Cruise Elemente gleich schon mal prä, also vorhergesagt zu haben, um gleich bestimmte Bedenken abzuwenden. Also das hatte schon für mich einen großen Unterhaltungswert. Habe ich auch das Gefühl gehabt, dass so ein Raunen durch das Publikum durchgegangen ist.
Ja, ich meine, die raunen ja die ganze Zeit.
Die raunen ja auch beim kleinsten anders. Nein, nicht dieses, dieses, dieses Schauspiel, sondern das ist wirklich nicht, die haben nicht, weil jetzt muss man offensichtlich jubeln, sondern das war was Unerwartetes, wo sie so ein, also ich hatte das Gefühl, dass das ist gut angekommen. Nicht nur bei mir.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall gut angekommen, da haben wir auch gar keine Sorgen. Ich hatte nur neulich so ein, auch so ein, Biometrie trifft es wahrscheinlich da nicht so ganz genau, aber so ein Video gesehen von einem Handtrockner. Weißt du, so diese komischen Handtrocknergebläse-Dinger war es, glaube ich.
Wo man die Hände wie in so eine Guettine reintut. Wo man das Gefühl hat, die werden dann so Piranhas. Die haben die Finger dann bis auf die Knochen abnagen.
Nee, nicht so ein Dyson.
Ja, das ist ein Dyson, ja.
Ich glaube, es war so ein Papierspender. Der Papierspender hatte auch einen optischen Sensor. Hältst du deine Hände drunter, dann wird dann halt Papier gespendet. Dann haben das Leute gemacht und es funktionierte auch. Dann kam jemand mit dunkler Hautfarbe. Dann hat es halt irgendwie nicht funktioniert. Da ist ja der Mangel an Diversität in diesem Unternehmen wahrscheinlich dazu geführt, dass sie nie auf die Idee gekommen sind. Mal ihr Feature, was sie dann ausgerollt haben, auch mal mit einer anderen Hautfarbe zu testen. Ich glaube, den Fehler wird Apple unter Garantie nicht gemacht haben. Nur wird sich halt zeigen, ob es Szenarien gibt, die sie auch mit dem akribischen Testen da nicht beigekommen sind. Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Es geht bei Apple nie ohne Geburtswehen ab.
Touch ID war eigentlich ziemlich flawless, muss man sagen.
Ein bisschen langsam am Anfang. Nicht zu sagen sehr langsam.
Am Anfang?
Ja, was war das? 4S hatte das. 5S. Also das war schon immer so drauflegen, 21, 22.
So lange hat das nicht gedauert, das stimmt nicht.
Na doch.
Nein, ich habe das ja gehabt, das war nicht so lange.
Ich habe es ja auch gehabt, ich habe es ja immer noch zuhause. Ja, aber es ist auf jeden Fall langsam. Ja, geschenkt.
So, gibt es denn noch was zum Thema X? Also ich würde das, ich muss mir sowieso ein neues Telefon mal demnächst zulegen und ich könnte mir inzwischen auch ein etwas größeres Telefon vorstellen. Die Kamera finde ich genial. Ich glaube, dass man damit tolle Bilder schießen kann. Das kann die andere auch schon, klar.
Aber dieser Porträtmodus, der ist schon wirklich krass. Ich habe das neulich mal gemacht, habe das das erste Mal benutzt und in so einer Open Air irgendwie, ich mach jetzt, ich knips mal schnell ein Foto, einfach mal draufgehalten und ehrlich gesagt, ich war total umgehauen von dem Ergebnis. Also es war absurd, wie gut das aussah. Und jetzt auch noch mit diesem Lighting, das haben wir noch gar nicht besprochen, dass diese Kamera in der Lage ist, auch noch, haben sie das gesagt, wie sie das eigentlich machen? Haben sie doch gesagt, wie sie das machen. Also das ganze Licht wird quasi per Software draufgerechnet, also die Lighting-Situation. Das heißt durch dieses ganze 3D-Profile etc. blenden sie den ganzen Hintergrund auch aus. Ich dachte mir gerade, wir haben so das Problem, Konferenz-Workshop-Situation, willst du mal schnell eine Übersichtstafel machen mit Fotos und so weiter? Wie schnell du mal so zack mal die Leute irgendwie alle mit einheitlichem weißen Hintergrund produzieren könntest, damit du da so halbwegs brauchbare Portraitfotos hast, ohne mit dem störenden Hintergrund. Geil, das ist echt eine Anwendung. Wobei es war irgendwie immer schwarz und nicht weiß, aber vielleicht kann man das irgendwie auch einstellen.
Also deswegen, mir sagt das zu, ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, was ich mir jetzt noch ein tolleres Smartphone vorstellen kann, weil irgendwo ist das Genre auch ein bisschen ausgereizt vom Formfaktor und ich finde jetzt diese komischen Akten, wie hattest du das da? Aktenordnerleiste, die da oben ist. Ich finde das fast schon sympathisch, dass aus technischen Gründen halt einfach auch mal die Technik sichtbar ist an der Stelle, dass da halt Sensoren sind und sie haben es, finde ich, dadurch, dass sie diese Leiste in die UI dann da integriert haben mit Statusanzeigen, finde ich legitim. Also im Gegenteil, es ist so ein Formfaktor, ich finde die ganz sympathisch.
Was muss man denn hier auf den Tisch legen dafür? Ich hab noch gar nicht geguckt, was hier die...
1150.
1150, aber dann hast du ja wahrscheinlich irgendwie nicht das rechts unten Modell, oder?
Natürlich nicht.
Ja eben, also gucken wir mal, was das rechts unten Modell kostet. Erstmal die ganzen CSS-Animationen. Wo ist der kaufen Button? Hier. So, Schnupsi, wählen.
Das dicke Modell 1120, äh 1320. Wenn du dann noch Apple Care hinzufügst, komm, fügen wir mal hinzu.
Ja, na Apple Care ist richtig teuer bei dem Teil, ne? 230 Euro.
Für Apple Care, genau.
Über 1500 Euro.
Alter Schwede. Gut wählen kann man jetzt nicht.
Es gibt nur 64 und 256.
Ja, für die anderen beiden auch. Das ist gemein, ne?
Ja, mit 128 würde ich mich wohlfühlen, ne?
Ne, ich wollt grad sagen, sind nicht die anderen alle 32 und 128?
Ne, 32 und 128.
Ja, aber ich würd so viele... Ja, aber ich würd halt viele Fotos machen. Ich glaube, da würde... Weil einfach diese Kamera so toll ist. Also ich glaube, das ist schon so ein Punkt, weswegen Speicher da auch ein Thema ist. Aber 128 würde... Ja, aber das ist ein Supercomputer.
Ich weiß. Aber nur gibt es das halt aus, ne?
Ja, aber dafür gibt's... Dafür kann man mal was anderes...
Ja, dann sind das die anderen jetzt, die nur noch...
Damit kann man aber mal eine Notebook-Generation überspringen. Wenn überhaupt noch mal...
Nützlich mal ehrlich, ich verstehe ja den Urge, dass man so was jetzt vielleicht haben will, weil man Developer ist, weil man sowieso immer das Neueste braucht, weil Geld keine Rolle spielt, etc.
Weil man angeben will.
Oder angeben.
Ich würde es zum Angeben.
Du würdest es zum Angeben machen, damit du endlich mal wieder was bist in deiner Peer Group.
Genau. Früher war das auch so. Als ich Max hatte, wurde man ja auch immer schief angeguckt, weil man sich so einen teuren Scheiß leistet. Hatten wir ja vorhin schon darüber gesprochen. Und da sprechen wir von ganz anderen Sorgen.
Also, man gibt jetzt so sehr viel Geld aus. Das Ding ist nur, ich glaube, es würde halt einfach noch dauern, bis diese Nützlichkeit kommt.
Ja, das ist ja das Early Adopter Problem.
Ja, Early Adopter Problem. Aber du kaufst jetzt halt einen Feature, eigentlich mehr so zum Angucken des Features. Aber nützlich wird es halt sein, naja, kurz bevor das nächste kommt. So, das heißt, wenn du die nächste Generation kaufst, dann ziehst du auch schon den vollen Benefit ab. Aber wenn du natürlich noch ein cooles Bonus haben willst...
Vielleicht können wir kurz mal sprechen. Der Tim hat mich eingeladen und ich sollte was mitbringen. Bei mir hat sich nämlich vor zwei Jahren das iPad Pro vorgestellt. Ich habe ja schon gesagt, dass ich so ein bisschen aus dem grafischen Bereich komme, ich mache Illustrationen. Hattet zu der Zeit genau überlegt, ob ich mir einen dieser typischen Displays besorge, die man an seinen Computer hängt und auf dem man das reine Slave-Ding, auf dem man quasi zeichnet, das aber kein Computer ist, aber natürlich einen Bildschirm ausgibt. Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, Mensch, dann habe ich mal die Auflösungen verglichen und den Preis und da war quasi das iPad Pro genauso teuer wie so ein Wacom-Display, auf dem man halt zeichnen kann. Dann habe ich mir gedacht, Mensch, aber dieses Wacom ist ja kein eigener Computer. Das iPad Pro ist immer noch ein Computer, also ein iPad noch dazu, auf dem man halt zeichnen kann. Und da war das für mich klar, das ist interessant. Und dann habe ich mir das auch gekauft. Und noch während ich es eingerichtet habe, wusste ich, dass ich nie wieder auf meinen Laptop gucken werde, es sei denn, es läuft ja gerade Fernsehen. Und das war also so ein Moment. Und seitdem kann ich einfach auch mit meinem kleinen iPhone 5S-Screen, der mir bis dahin komplett gelangt hat, als ich dann von dem iPad Pro wieder auf mein iPhone geschaut habe, das war nicht mehr erträglich für mich. Alles war gedrängt, gequetscht, komplett nicht mehr akzeptabel. Und seitdem bin ich einfach auch unzufrieden mit der Größe des iPhones, was ich vom Formfaktor her wunderschön und toll fand. Und deswegen brauche ich jetzt auch ein größeres iPhone, weil ich bin da komplett versaut durch das iPad Pro.
Ich habe manchmal in der Firma sogar noch ein 4S in der Hand. Das ist klein. Vor allem, du hast das Gefühl, wo ist das iPhone? Meine Hand ist noch nicht voll.
Wofür nutzt du denn dein iPad Pro?
Für alles.
Man muss ja auch mal dazu sagen, du hast das große.
Das iPad Pro vor zwei Jahren wurde ja nur das große vorgestellt.
Um es noch mal klarzumachen, wir reden hier von dem 12, 9 Zoll Teil. Das ist echt eine Ansage. Kannst du mir das mal kurz anlocken? Ich habe das auch noch nicht so oft im Betrieb gehabt. Ich habe jetzt, hatten wir das in der letzten Sendung mit dem neuen iPad?
Ja, ich habe es heute auch wieder dabei.
Hast du das schon mal ausprobiert, das neue?
Nö.
Mit dem Stift meine ich?
Ich habe doch einen Stift.
Aber mit dem neuen Abtastfrequenzen-Updates?
Nee, das hat aber die gleiche Abtastfrequenz.
Hätte ich gesagt, der Stift vom iPad Pro ist so gut, ich weiß jetzt nicht, was da noch viel besser sein soll. Aber gut, das weiß man. Darf ich mal?
Willst du mit Stift?
Ich hätte mal gerne den Stift und einen Notizteil.
Da habe ich einen echten Sedlag, das ist natürlich super.
Übrigens, meine Mine ist schon total abgegrabbelt, weil ich habe damit wirklich viel gearbeitet. Diese Spitze, die ist bestimmt nicht mehr vergleichbar mit der von Roddi. Ich merke keinen Unterschied.
Was bei dem ist, das Grollen, das sieht man.
Hier ist schon noch ein bisschen Lack. Aber es geht wahrscheinlich auch. Was machst du denn damit?
Interessanterweise... Schreibst du oder malst du? Ich benutze es für bestimmte Illustrations-Zwischenschritte. Also die eigentliche Entwurfsarbeit mache ich nicht. Ich mache also keine Scribbles, wie viele Leute das machen. Ich benutze es wirklich für, man würde jetzt sagen, für Rotusche arbeiten oder für kolorieren. Für ganz, ganz definierte analoge Verfahren, die für mich sinnvoll sind, weil ich sie... Ich muss keine Farben nachkaufen. Ein Tuschefast kann mir nicht umfallen und sich auf die gesamte Zeichnung ergießen. Man kann auch mal solche Schritte zurück machen.
Es geht Bereiche, wo eigentlich die wichtigen gestalterischen und konzeptionellen Entscheidungen alle schon getroffen sind. Und es geht jetzt wirklich nur noch um die Final Touches. Also, dass man bestimmte Sachen hervorhebt, dass man eine weiße Linie, einen Blitzer macht, um Kontraste hervorzuheben, oder dass man Konturen verstärkt, damit man einfach etwas sichtbarer machen kann. Aber alles ist schon da. Das heißt, oftmals sind es, zum Beispiel, ich arbeite mit einem Kollegen zusammen, der arbeiten von mir, die im Bleistift sind, die tuscht er ab, ganz analog, schickt mir sehr, sehr hoch aufgelöste schwarz-weiß JPEGs und die bearbeite ich dann weiter. Und das natürlich mit einer gewissen Feinheit. Ich komme noch nicht ganz los vom Rechner, also vom klassischen Mac, weil bestimmte Dinge so pro ist es dann doch nicht in der grafischen Bereich, wenn es zum Beispiel darum geht, dass ich hoch aufgelösten A0-Poster machen will. Das ist mit den Programmen, die verfügbar sind, so nicht machbar. Da muss man dann einfach auf der klassischen Schiene bleiben. Aber viel interessanter jetzt, ich hab's mir eigentlich wirklich gekauft gehabt als Arbeitsgerät, aber interessanterweise hat es instantan alles übernommen, was so mein Leanback-Modus am Rechner anbelangt. Das heißt, was man surfen, man liest irgendwelche Webseiten und sonst was. Also alles, wo ich selber nicht schreibe und tue, das mach ich quasi nicht. Ich hab ja auch keine Tastatur dazu gekauft, sondern wenn ich mal irgendwas notiere oder so, dann nutze ich diese Soft-Tastatur. Aber was für mich ein wirklicher, also toll ist, sind die heutigen Webseiten. Auf so einem großen Format fühlen sie sich eben schon fast an wie eine Zeitung. Das Gewicht ist natürlich ein bisschen größer. Man muss es so ein bisschen ausbalancieren, wenn man das so auf dem, also ich werde da, es ermüdet mich nicht. Aber was wirklich eine Killer-Geschichte ist, ist Wheatly. Das ist eine Magazin-Flatrate. Das heißt, ich habe jetzt quasi einen gesamten Bahnhof-Kiosk.
Wheatly, ist das so was wie dieses holländische Ding?
Das ist das hier.
Ach so, so richtige Magazine.
Genau, richtige Magazine kriege ich als PDF. Und über 1700 haben sie momentan im Portfolio, kostet 10 Euro im Monat. Und ich habe jetzt mal so 250 Favoriten für mich herausgestellt.
Wie viel kostet das?
10 Euro im Monat.
250 Papiermagazine?
Nein, 1800, aber ich habe 250 davon mich in so eine Favoritenliste reingetan.
Aber du könntest alle 1800 lesen?
Ja.
Für 10 Euro.
Ja, und plus, dass sie natürlich einen Backlit-Katalog haben. Das heißt, es sind viele 5, 6, 10.000 Magazine sofort immer verfügbar. Und ich lese da relativ kursorisch, auch teilweise englische, was weiß ich, indische Motorradmagazine. Ja, hier, Tim hat jetzt gerade Sportbild auf. Alles Sachen, die ich mir nie um Kiosk kaufen würde. Aber wenn jeden Tag 12 bis 15 neue Magazine dazu kommen, da gucke ich mal drüber. Und dann würde ich zum Beispiel auch mal in ein Sportbild reingucken, wenn ich das Gefühl habe, es ist interessant. Und das Leseerlebnis ist dann quasi eins zu eins, finde ich, eigentlich sogar besser, weil eine Papierzeitschrift ist dann von hinten nicht beleuchtet. Und das heißt, die Brillanz, die ich habe über das Display, ist einfach toll. Manchmal muss man bei doppelseitigen Geschichten, also normalerweise lese ich quasi im Porträtmodus, bei manchen Layouts ist es dann aber auch mal sinnvoll, was Tim jetzt gemacht hat, das iPad zu drehen und in den Landscape-Modus zu gehen, dann hat man also eine Doppelseite vor sich. Dann ist aber das Lesen ein bisschen mühselig, weil es einfach ein bisschen sehr schwieriges Augenpulver ist.
Da bräuchte man dann nochmal ein 18 Zoll iPad Pro.
Das wäre überhaupt für mich, man sollte zumindest mal überlegen bei Apple, weil ich glaube, das auch nochmal zum Anfang der Show hin, Apple könnte aus meiner Sicht mit so grafischen Profiprodukten durchaus einen Markt entwickeln und ein iPad Pro mit vielleicht einem 13 Zoll Bilddiagonale müsste eigentlich technisch noch machbar sein.
Die 13 Zoll, das ist doch 13 Zoll.
Nee, das ist 10, 5 Zoll Bilddiagonale.
Nee, das ist das, was ich hier habe, 10, 5.
Nee, du hast 12, 9.
Okay, dann eine, dann, okay.
Deswegen meinte ich ja so 18 Zoll.
Nee, 15. Also ein 15er würde schon gefühlt sich nach A3 anfühlen. Ja, mit einem besonders hochauflösenden.
Zentimeter mehr Diagonale, das macht schon eine Menge aus.
Also das, ich glaube, ich würde dafür auch 2500 Euro für ausgeben. Mit links, also nicht links unten, sondern Mitte.
Herr Schiller, haben Sie das genotiert? Der hört ja immer Freak Show, ne? Die machen ja auch mal alles, was wir hier verlangen.
Also dann könnte man es auch als Grafikkabin noch wesentlich besser nutzen.
Das ist ja echt interessant, um so Presse zu verfolgen, aber das sieht da sich alle, ich meine, das ist absurd, weil du normalerweise so PDF-Abos irgendwie teilst, irgendwie 10 Euro pro Magazin. Wie haben die denn das gemacht?
Ja, das ist erstmal ein Versuch, also so ein paar Schwergewichte, also Stern und Spiegel weigern sich noch, aber ich glaube, Galak könnte man abonnieren. Was wichtig ist. Condé Nast ist mit ein paar Produkten dabei. Für mich bin ja so ein Auto- und Motorradfreak. Die Motorpresse Stuttgart ist relativ mit ihren Flaggschiffen drin vertreten. Springer auch mit ihren Autobild-Titeln. Also mich, ich würde wahrscheinlich 20 oder 25 Euro mindestens für Zeitschriften auf Papier, da habe ich vorher ausgegeben und jetzt ist das mit 10 Euro abgegolten und ich habe keine Stapel von Zeitschriften mehr, die so halb angelesen bei mir rumliegen. Also es ist ein Traum. Und damit hat sich das noch mal das Erlebnis von diesem iPad noch mal wesentlich verbessert. Das war schon vorher, wie gesagt, ich habe es nicht mehr aus der Hand genommen in dem Moment, wo ich es eingerichtet habe, was ich selbst nicht erwartet hatte. Ich wollte es als Profi Grafiktablett mit Zusatznutzen. Eigentlich habe ich es gekauft und es ist genau umgekehrt gewesen, ist jetzt meine digitale Standardmaschine mit Zusatznutzen, ein professionelles Grafiktablett.
Welche Maschine hast du noch zusätzlich?
Ich habe noch ein sieben Jahre altes MacBook Pro 13 Zoll.
Wirst du dir noch ein neues kaufen?
Ich werde mir wohl noch einmal ein letztes MacBook Pro 13 Zoll kaufen und ich glaube, das wird mein letzter Computer werden. Ja, weil wenn jetzt schon dieses alte MacBook Pro nach wie vor vollkommen funktional für mich ist, das Einzige, was mich stört, ist, dass es halt kein Retina-Display hat. Die Geschwindigkeit ist nach wie vor ausreichend. Dann wird das neue zehn oder zwölf Jahre halten. Und danach gibt es keine, also nichts mehr, was, ich glaube, dann wird es das nicht mehr geben als Gerätegattung. Jetzt, 2030. Okay, dann... Wenn ich im Januar 2018 mir das Gerät kaufe, es zwölf Jahre behalte, dann ist es 2030, dann gibt es keine Verbrennungsmotoren mehr.
Ja, die gibt es schon früher nicht mehr.
Na, da wäre ich mir nicht so ganz sicher.
Aber Apple bringt mich ja jetzt schon weg von dem Laptop, irgendwie mit ihrem Scheißdreck. Aber ich könnte halt mit so einem iPad, sorry, also weiß ich nicht, ob das irgendwie eine Frage der Gewohnheit ist, aber die Dinge, die ich tue an meinem Computer, habe ich bisher an einem iPad noch nicht hinbekommen.
Also deswegen, so ein MacBook Pro brauche ich so als Device of Last Resort. Also bestimmte Dinge funktionieren oder will ich... Also Mails schreiben, irgendwie auf den Bildschirm tippen, irgendwie es geht gar nicht. Ja, das meine ich. Also ich will darauf nicht... Nur Mails schreiben brauchst du nicht mit dem neuesten und hottesten MacBook.
Ich gucke jetzt einfach nur noch in meinen iPhone und dann wird ja klar meine emotionale Linie kommuniziert.
Dann wird sofort ein Standardkommentar erzeugt.
Tim, du hast doch eh eine Apple Watch, da kannst du auch deine gesamten E-Mails sektieren, also brauchst du gar kein Notebook mehr.
Bist du jetzt bei mir oder suchst du jetzt alle Magazine durch? Du kannst auch mal in... Nee, jetzt bist du in Magazine. Favoriten sind meine, die ich ausgewählt habe. Magazine ist alles. Du bist jetzt im Alles.
Ja, ja, das ist irre, was alles so produziert wird.
Was ist auch interessant, ich hab Tip und City, die sind auch drin, sodass ich auf einmal etwas, was für mich als Berlin-Mensch so komplett gestorben war, weil manche Dinge kriegt man ja doch nicht mehr mit, weil die immer noch so behaftet sind und irgendwelche Theatergeschichten und sowas. Und dann einfach mal so ein bisschen einmal die Woche durch City zu scrollen und so ein bisschen zu gucken, was ist jetzt gerade so angesagt in der Stadt. Das kostet nämlich irgendwie eine Viertelstunde.
Oder was glaubt die City, was gerade angesagt ist in der Stadt? Das war ja immer so mehr mein Problem mit der City.
Ja, aber es deckt sich halt noch nicht voll konkurrent mit dem, was man sonst so abonniert hat über Facebook oder Twitter.
Macht auch die Werbung irgendwie mehr Sinn?
Ja, vor allen Dingen finde ich es sehr gut, dass sie es wenigstens vermutlich auch deswegen mit gutem Gewissen in dieses Sweetly einspeisen können, weil sie ihre Reichweite für die Werbung damit zumindest versprechen können, dass sie sich dann... Ich gucke jetzt so viel mehr auf Werbung von Magazinen, die ich vorher nicht mal gedacht hätte, dass ich da draufschauen würde.
Weil?
Weil...
Weil du sie überhaupt liest oder weil du da mehr drauf...
Weil ich überhaupt nicht wusste, dass es sie gibt.
Ja, die Magazine oder die Werbung?
Die Magazine. Ja, wo wusste ich, dass es eine indische Variante von K gibt oder sonst was, ja. Was ich aber nicht wusste, weil es war einfach ein englisches Magazin, dann merkte ich auf einmal, das ist eine englischsprachige indische Motorradzeitschrift. Ich meine, es hilft jetzt den indischen Werbetreibenden nicht so sehr, dass ich jetzt draufgeguckt habe, aber...
Aber es hat ihnen auch nicht geschadet.
Es hat ihnen nicht geschadet und wer weiß.
Es müsste noch einen vertikalen Scrollbar geben. Das ist ein bisschen doof.
Und es gibt wirklich erstaunlich... Ja, es geht einfach mal in so einen gut sortierten internationalen Bahnhof-Kiosk oder am Flughafen in so ein Ding und stellt euch vor, ihr habt das alles in eurem iPad sofort. Also die Ladezeiten für die Magazine sind so etwa 6 bis 8 Sekunden. Dann hat man alles drauf. Man kann sofort anfangen zu lesen, weil die ersten zwei, drei Seiten werden ja sofort schon geliefert.
Lass mich mal eine Frage stellen. Die Antwort ist wahrscheinlich sowieso nein. Aber kann man da Volltextsuche suchen?
Ich glaube, nein. Ich glaube, das ist reine Dummie. Manchmal werden die Links, ich glaube, du kannst die Links teilweise anklicken.
Man kann die Links anklicken, ja.
Die werden hervorgerufen. Aber ich glaube, das ist eher so ein Zufall, weil jemand beim PDF, beim Acrobat wahrscheinlich diese Funktion irgendwie nicht ausgestellt hat. Aber ansonsten eine Volltextsuche in diesen Geschichten glaube ich nicht.
Na ja, man darf ja noch träumen.
Nein, nein, du hast ja auch vollkommen recht.
Du hast selbstverständlich eine Volltextsuche.
Ah, ich hab's einfach, ich hatte gerade das Bedürfnis.
In dem Magazin zumindest. Also über alle Magazine weiß ich jetzt grad nicht. Auf jeden Fall innen. Ich glaube sogar das. Sehr wohl.
Oh, sehr gut.
Also jetzt kann ich mal nach Pritlove suchen.
Weil das ist für mich der Use Case von Büchern, von digitalen Büchern.
Das ist ja meine ganz neue Form des Ego-Surfings. Über mich wird geschrieben im enormen Magazin 0616. Ich weiß noch nicht mal, dass es das gibt.
Wieso bist du denn auf die Idee gekommen, dort nach dir zu suchen?
Na Ego-Surfing, ich habe halt einfach jetzt gerade mal meinen Namen, der ist relativ guter Suchbegriff.
Das stimmt.
Und was finden wir hier? Informieren und engagieren, Titelgeschichte, wichtige Plattformen und Organisationen, die dabei helfen, sich im Dschungel der Digitalisierung zurechtzufinden. Erste Erwähnung, Logbuch Netzpolitik. Wenn ich dich habe, Podcast über das Netzpolitische Geschehen mit Linus Neumann und Tim Pritlove.
Wenn der Tim dann fertig ist, würde ich auch gerne mal mit dem Spielzeug rumspielen, und zwar in einem Grafikprogramm, weil ich gerade schon an... Ich bin jetzt voll im Ego-Surfing.
Das ist ja geil.
Kann man Tim mal kurz mit was anderem begeistern? Ich meine, das ist jetzt...
Jetzt hast du ja echt ein Fass aufgemacht. Ich meine, das ist natürlich jetzt mal Presselspiegel ganz anders, ne?
Gute Bildseiten kann man natürlich, was ich schön finde, durch die Screenshots dann ja auch entsprechend sichern.
Jetzt wird es noch härter.
Steht dein Name neben irgendetwas, was mit Union zu tun hat?
Nein, in den Engeling Times gibt es irgendeinen Tim Pritlove, der tatsächlich irgendwie beim Angeln gewonnen hat. Jetzt bin ich aber ein bisschen...
Ah, Tim hat seinen Namensfetter gefunden.
Ich finde es bloß gerade jetzt hier nicht auf der Seite.
Kein Highlight.
Also es ist nicht geheiligetet, ja genau.
Gott sei Dank noch ein Flaw gefunden.
Na, ich finde immer Flaws. Trotzdem irgendwie krass. Und wo wird es noch? Netq, Next Economy Magazine, nochmal hier Engling Times.
Dein Namensfetter ist ein ordentlicher Fischer.
Ich wusste gar nicht, das Angeln auf Englisch, einfach Engling.
Ich auch nicht.
Engeln. Ich hätte gedacht, das wäre jetzt ein Falsfriend. Ich hätte mich nie getraut. Ich hätte immer gesagt Fishing.
Terry, Terry Pritlove.
Terry Pritlove.
Vielleicht sollten Terry und Tim mal angeln gehen.
Aber ohne Highlighting ist das Ganze ja irgendwie nur halb gewonnen.
So ein Fisch geangelt.
Aber ich muss jetzt wirklich nochmal eine Lanze für dieses Gerät. Das ist ein totaler Gamechanger und ich muss es wirklich sagen, da macht es die Größe aus, einfach weil das Lesen, das Pad ist etwa so groß wie die Magazine, die es abbildet und selbst bei einer Zeitung, die es natürlich nicht gleich abbildet, die Website von Tageszeitungen wirken doch wesentlich Tageszeitungsmäßiger im Porträtmod als alles, was man sonst so vom normalen Computerscreen so erlebt. Abgesehen davon, dass man ja darauf rumscrollen kann und drauf touchen kann, ich finde es super. Und vorher hätte ich auch immer gesagt, das iPad ist so eine Kategorie von Gerät, das ich überhaupt nicht brauche. Und dann sind jetzt einfach der Stift und die Größe hat dazu geführt, dass es für mich zu einer total relevanten Kategorie geworden ist und ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass irgendwas bei der Apple Watch passiert, dass genau es dann auch sein kann, dass ich dann auch dieses Gerät brauche. Das weiß ich noch nicht, was das sein könnte, aber ich will das für die Zukunft gar nicht ausschließen.
Also was für mich den Unterschied gemacht hat, war ja irgendwie iOS 11, weil ich habe da die Beta auf einem alten iPad installiert und das war irgendwie so viel besser plötzlich, dass ich dachte so, ah, ja, und dann habe ich angefangen, das wieder mehr zu benutzen. Da hat es mich genervt, weil es so langsam war. Und dann hatte ich in der Firma halt mal dieses 10, 5 in der Hand und habe da mal... Und also dieses Display, dieses... Letztes Mal wurde mir vorgeworfen, ich klänge, als würde ich sagen, Truthand-Display. Aber es ist natürlich das True Tone Display. Also gerade mit diesem von Apple mitgelieferten Hintergrundbild kann man das total gut sehen, was das Ding für einen Farbraum hat. Das ist unglaublich. Und da war ich dann sold.
Das meint es ja noch nicht. Das ist, glaube ich, erst mit dieser Generation sowohl auf das Kleine als auch auf das Große überspielt worden. Wie gesagt, ich warte jetzt noch und hoffe, dass die Freak Show wirklich in Cupertino gehört wird. Bringt bitte so ein 14, 3 Zoll oder keine Ahnung, ein Riesen-iPad raus.
Ja, Terry Pritlove hat irgendwie 148 Pfundkapfen rausgezogen. Mann, sowas wird als Zeitung produziert. Unglaublich, oder?
Seit hunderten von Jahren macht man das so.
Wie viel wiegt das?
Du hast doch da die Dings auf dem... Ach so, der Pencil.
Aber ist das nicht das neue Pro, was ich hier gerade habe?
Also das Readly ist ja wirklich eine...
Es ist für die Größe nicht schwer, aber ich glaube, wenn man den ganzen Tag in der Hand hat... Also ich benutze es halt sehr gerne für Notizen in irgendwelchen Meetings und so. Das ist halt einfach netter, als wenn man da jetzt irgendwie mit seinem Rechner und aufgeklappt und tippel tippel.
Der Stift, der ist echt schon heftig benutzt worden. Es kann sein, dass der nicht ganz so spitzfindig ist, wie der von Roddi.
Also bei meinem war noch eine zweite Spitze dabei.
Bei mir auch, aber die will ich noch nicht anbrechen. Das ist quasi so meine stille Reserve.
Kann man die Spitzen nachkaufen?
Natürlich, aber du weißt doch, bei Apple kostet das dann Vermögen.
Die Strafgebühr, wie hier manche immer sagen.
Pressreader, das wird hier gerade im Chat genannt. Das ist quasi nochmal so ein ähnlicher Ansatz für Zeitungen.
Ehrlich gesagt, Wheatley ist mir als Facebook-Werbung aufgefallen. Es ist mir ein bisschen unangenehm, das zu gestehen. Aber Facebook-Werbung ist inzwischen auf mich sehr, sehr gut eingeschossen. Und wir werden da richtig nützliche Verbrauchertipps in die Timeline geschossen, indiziert. Sodass ich sagen muss, es ist nicht alles schlecht mit Facebook.
Da kann ich nichts zu sagen. Ich bin nach wie vor Facebook-abstinent, kann ich sagen. Da muss man ja vorher abhängig gewesen sein.
Agnostisch, ich bin agnostisch.
Heide.
Ja, ich glaube, Agnostiker sind ja gegen, also ich weiß nicht genau, wie Heide so definiert ist.
Heide ist jemand, der das Licht noch nicht gesehen hat.
Heide ist so eine Feindbezeichnung von den Christen, für alle anderen, die eigentlich auch an was glauben. Aber die sind ja auch so im Glaubensbereich. Ich bin ja eher glaubensagnostisch. Ich bin ja auch kein Atheist. Ich schon. Du lässt einfach Gott einen guten Mann sein. Ich hab da drüber nachgedacht. Ich dachte mir, mich als Atheisten zu bezeichnen, wäre eigentlich schon eine Zumutung. Weil das würde ja dann bedeuten, dass ich zumindest die Energie da reinstecken muss, auch noch gegen so ein Konzept zu sein. Ich gehe eher dazu über und nenne die anderen Leute Proteisten.
Dir ist wahrscheinlich, Hauptsache Gott glaubt an dich.
Schöner hätte ich es nicht sagen können Gregor.
Na ja, also aber das Gegenteil von Atheist ist ja Teeist und nicht Protist oder wie hast du das genannt? Proteist. Nein, Teeist. Weil sonst wär man ja Anti-Teeist. Also Pro und Anti ist ja das Gegenteil voneinander.
Aber Protist klingt ja schon wieder irgendwie normal.
Und eine lateinische Vorsilbe an ein griechisches Wort ist sowieso irgendwie, aber lassen wir das.
Du meinst, du bist völlig verkackt. Na Hauptsache, Gott glaubt an mich.
Er wird es bestimmt tun, Tim. Er wird es bestimmt tun.
Wo wir jetzt... Wo wir jetzt gerade in dieser religiösen...
Ein Hurricane oder zwei könnte er mal wieder vorbeischicken...
.Demissionen angelangt sind. Wollten wir noch nicht noch mal über die Zukunft von Apple sprechen?
Wollten wir unbedingt.
Ja, gibste eine?
Die Frage. Ich...
Lange Zeit war es halt wirklich so, dass man gesagt hat jetzt zwei Drittel des, ob nun Erlös oder Umsatz oder Gewinn, stand von diesem, dieser iPhone-Sparte. Da kommt aber nichts Entscheidendes mehr. Ob das iPhone X oder iPhone X, wie wir Gläubige ja jetzt dann sagen...
Das ist ein ganz altes Zitat.
X that's 10?
Ja, als Mac OS 10 aufkam, wurden auch ständig die Leute verbessert, dass es nicht X, sondern 10 wäre. Und jetzt ist das iPhone 10... Ich finde es ein bisschen uncanny, dass nach Mac OS 10 jetzt das iPhone 10 kommt.
Ich dachte auch, nachdem sie endlich losgeworden sind.
Und dann aber auch das ganze Branding total ähnlich ist. Also irgendwie da, naja, Apple, da müssen wir nochmal reden.
Für mich ist es X. Ich lasse mir einen X nicht für eine Zahl vormachen.
Das ist gut. Wenigstens einer bleibt dran.
Sonst müssen ja die iPhone Roman X. Dann bin ich voll bei denen, aber nicht so. Nicht auf diese...
Die iPhone Roman X?
Die römischen Eier des iPhones.
Gibt es eine Zukunft? Ich meine, jetzt irgendwie...
Definiere erst mal Zukunft bitte an dem Zusammenhang.
Also neue exorbitante Wachstumsfelder, in denen quasi diese Erfolgsgeschichte mit ähnlich großartigen Zugewinn weiter wachsen kann, was ja erstmal unwahrscheinlich ist.
Meinst du, das ist jetzt so wirtschaftlich, gesellschaftlich?
Ja, also wo man wirklich sagen würde, okay, vielleicht diese iPhone-Geschichte, irgendwann hat jeder eins und auch ein sechs Jahre altes iPhone.
Was würdest du sozusagen als Benchmark setzen? Muss es unbedingt jetzt nochmal so ein Ding sein wie iPhone? Oder reicht es auch, wenn es überhaupt nur einzelne Produktkategorien geben, die sagen wir mal so erfolgreich sind wie iPod?
Ne, mit so einem Quatsch, das befriedigt nicht.
Oder müsste es so einen Umsatz haben wie Facebook?
Ja, es müsste so fünf bis zehn Jahre mindestens einfach mal der Umsatz verdoppelt und der Gewinn verdreifacht sein. Von Apple.
Also jetzt nur so groß wie alle Konkurrenten sein mit einem einzelnen Segment reichlich?
Die wachsen ja auch.
Es ist egal, aber es gibt ja Segmente bei Apple, die sind so groß wie Facebook und die sind irgendwie auch schon wichtig.
Ja, aber das ist halt so. Das sind so die Forderungen, die ich so lese, weil ich ja jetzt durch Wheatly auch auf ganz, ganz exotische Finanzen lese. Ich lese Börse online und auch solche Geschichten.
Ich bin Zahlexperten.
Und es ist dann ja ganz interessant, also es gibt zum Beispiel eine Zeitschrift, die heißt Euro am Sonntag, ich glaube, die kommt eher aus einem dubiosen Verlag, aber das sind so richtige Börsenhainis und die haben einen sehr, sehr klugen und schlauen Blick auf alle möglichen Firmen. Und ein paar Firmen, da kenne ich mich aus, so aus meiner Spezialexpertentumperspektive. Und wenn ich dann lese, was die da schreiben, dann hat das immer Hand und Fuß. Und wenn ich so die normale Tageszeitung lese, dann wird SUV mit Sportwaren übersetzt. Das ist so das Level des hochgelobten FAZ-Wirtschaftsteils. Es heißt vor allen Dingen mal Utility Vehicle, also Nutzfahrzeug. Ein Sports Utility Vehicle ist also ein freizeit- und sportorientiertes Nutzfahrzeug. Das wäre die technische Übersetzung für SUV. Ja und daraus macht dann die deutsche Übersetzung ein. Ford hat mit seinen Sportwagen, der meistverkaufte Ding, seinen Sportwagen, der F-150 oder so.
Die korrekte Formulierung hätte geheißen Sportbollerwagen.
Es ist ein Nutzfahrzeug für den Privatgebrauch oder so würde man das in Amtsdeutsch übersetzen. Nutz-Pkw. Vor allen Dingen nicht im gewerblichen Einsatz. Ein Nutz-Pkw. Und da sehe ich natürlich schon, dass die jetzt immer schauen, dass Apple sich von einer Wachstumsgeschichte in so ein defensives, stabiles, womöglich auch stabiles, aber die Fantasie fehlt. Und irgendwo habe ich ja schon das Gefühl, nicht von einer börslichen Betrachtung, sondern mehr von dem Impetus, den Apple selber für sich definiert, dass sie schon sagen, wir wollen diese Welt verändern. Und wir haben am Anfang auch schon mal gesprochen mit ihrer Retail-Geschichte, dass sie sich offensichtlich auch der Stadterneuerung, zumindest in Amerika, verpflichtet fühlen. Sie haben diesen Impetus. Ich finde, was Letty gesagt hat, dieser Gesundheitsmarkt, das könnte über die nächsten 15 bis 25 Jahre eine Wahnsinnswachstumsgeschichte werden. Da sehen wir aber noch nicht so diese Killer-App, die sofort aufspringt. Das glaube ich auch viel, viel komplizierter. Das ist noch komplizierter als die Verhandlung mit den fünf Musik-Majors gewesen ist, um quasi in allen Kliniken der Welt, dass jeder Chefarzt mit einem iPad oder mit einem AR-Kit rumläuft und dann so die Haut scannt und so fort, picken dann so Diagnosen Big Data-gestütz auf, was der Patient so haben könnte. Ich habe dann auch überlegt, was könnte Apple jetzt machen? Es kam ja immer die Sache mit dem Apple Car. Und das haben sie jetzt offensichtlich beerdigt. Weil wenn man jetzt nicht nur als Software oder CarPlay oder sowas, sondern jetzt mit einem richtigen Auto, das aus einer Apple-Fabrik fällt, sehe ich nicht mehr. Weil Tesla hat als First Mover diese Pionierrolle eingenommen und den, zumindest vor allem in den deutschen Automobilkonzernen, geht ja nun wirklich der Arsch auf Grundeis. Sie haben jetzt wirklich gemerkt und das sieht man ja jetzt auch hier in den Kreisen. Es wird ja tatsächlich auch in der Freak Show über Automobile gesprochen. Ich war bei einer privaten Geburtstagsparty und da war ein Gast mit einem Tesla da. Das war, als würden wir im Jahre 1917 sein und eine Geburtstagsparty und der erste Mensch mit einem Automobil kommt vorbei. Und alle haben ihn, komm lass uns mal rausgehen, den Tesla anschauen. Und irgendwann sagte der, naja, willst du den mal mitfahren? Der hat dann wirklich drei Tesla-Experiences ausgegeben. Also soweit ist es schon. Ist das offiziell?
Nein, nein, nein. My other car is a reservation. Mein schöner roter Hoodie, der immer wieder Freunde findet.
Und das zeigt ja, dass das was bewegt. Und das ist vor, ich glaube vor zehn Monaten oder so, erzählte mir ein Schulfreund mit einem halb erwachsenen Sohn, dass der gesagt hat, der Auto kommt gar nicht in Frage, sei denn, es ist ein Tesla. Also wenn 16-jährige Teenager sagen, ich will keinen Führerschein, es sei denn, du bezahlst mir den Führerschein und ich bekomm den Tesla, dann mach ich auch einen Führerschein. Dann weißt du, da ist was wirklich gepflanzt worden. Das haben auch die deutschen Automobilkonzerne jetzt gemerkt. Ich glaube, es wird jetzt wirklich, die holen auf, es gibt ihnen 50-50 Chancen, dass sie nicht in den Nokia-Abgrund fallen.
Allen?
Den Deutschen schon. Das sind ja nicht so viele. Das sind ja nur drei Großkonzerne, BMW, Daimler und VW. Beim Rest gebe ich keine Garantien. Also was international passiert, kann ich nicht. Aber die drei sind aufgewacht und deswegen glaube ich, und die ja auch das Premium-Segment international bespielen, mit Tesla zusammen. Also Tesla hat mit dem Model S mehr verkauft als Audi, BMW, Porsche, Mercedes mit ihren jeweiligen Oberklassendimousinen im amerikanischen Markt zusammengenommen. Das ist, auch andere neutrale Länder wie der Schweiz sieht das ähnlich aus. Das haben die schon registriert. Da wird jetzt wirklich für Apple als komplett sachfremder Anbieter sich da rein zu hauen sehr, sehr schwierig, ist meine Meinung. Also das hätten die vor drei, vier Jahren, hätte es eine Chance gegeben. Und die Deutschen hatten zu der Zeit mehr Angst vor Apple und Google, von Google Car oder nur Apple Car, weil die auch schon da rumgefahren sind, zumindest bei Google sichtbar. Und deswegen glaube ich, es hat sich die Lücke geschlossen für Apples, meine Meinung. Aber was haltet ihr denn von von Apple Home? Und zwar im Sinne von, dass Apple einfach Häuser baut. Ich meine standardisierte Prefab Designer Häuser, die alle schon alle zukünftigen Schnittstellen haben, damit das Apple Home Kit richtig funktioniert. Alles von Steve, wie heißt der, wie heißt der? Von Johnny Ive. This home is created for a creative people who live the lifestyle of individuality. From first class materials, aluminum window frames, slightly.
Ja, ne, das skaliert nicht.
Das glaube ich nicht. Warum sollte das nicht skalieren? Also sie könnten Millionen von Häusern in verschiedenen Märkten nach bestimmten standardisierten Geschichten dann natürlich wieder als Franchise-System bauen.
Ja, aber so ein Haus ist eine extrem, extrem individualisierte Sache. Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie irgendwie, dass...
Ist jeder Rechner nach ein paar Wochen Benutzung auch...
So ein Apple-Container irgendwo auf der Wiese stellen mit Anschluss und so, das ist schwer vorstellbar für mich.
Also ich hätte probiert, weil ich glaube, Apple hätte zu der Zeit oder auch nach wie vor so viel Finanzkraft, dass sie wirklich so eine Art Lego-System, aber wirklich Lego, wie wir es kennen, mit einem hochgradigen Modularität, um für verschiedenste Märkte in dem bestimmten Mittelklassebereich ein toller Häuser zu bauen.
Da ist zu wenig User-Interface dran an so einem Haus, glaube ich, für Apple.
Also Haus sehe ich nicht. Ganz ehrlich, das ist irgendwie nicht... Im Haus sind sie am Fernseher, da wollen sie der Hub sein, das ist Apple TV, das sind so diese Strategien, dass die nicht sonderlich gut funktionieren. Bisher ist noch mal eine andere Abteilung, aber ein Haus bauen an einem Haus selber ist ja erst mal überhaupt nichts dran, was jetzt irgendwie Apple auszeichnet. Und wenn überhaupt, dann müssten wir dann...
Redest du jetzt von Robotik?
Du redest von einem Haus, was sie selber bauen?
Nein, ich rede von einem Smart Home, das natürlich von Latinos, die aus Mexiko illegal eingewandert sind, über zertifizierte dreifache Sub-Sub-Sub-Unternehmer natürlich ganz klassisch gebaut werden. Aber ich meine, Apple hat gerade ein Haus gebaut für, keine Ahnung, anderthalb Milliarden.
Ja, aber ein Haus bauen ist halt eine Sache. Eine Produktionsstraße für Häuser bauen ist eine andere Sache.
Sie sollen ein System vorgeben, das dann von standardisierten Leuten, aber wie gesagt, das wäre so.
Da muss ich dich jetzt mal ausbremsen. Also das halte ich jetzt wirklich ein bisschen für unfug. Da lasse ich mich auch gerne zitieren, dann später.
Da habe ich auch gar keine Probleme.
Wenn man sich jetzt anschaut, wo Apple gerade so seine Karten hat. Was sie ja, was man ihnen gerade nicht vorwerfen kann, obwohl ihnen das lange vorgeworfen wurde, ist, dass sie diesen Machine Learning Zug verpassen. Sieht für mich so aus, als ob sie die nicht verpasst haben und dass sie da auch vielleicht nicht jetzt unbedingt an allen vorbeiziehen und davon sind, aber sie sind stark aufgestellt. Sie gehen das Ganze mal wieder sehr systematisch an. Das wird irgendwie ins Betriebssystem, in ihre Hardware bis in ihre Prozessoren hinein integriert. Das ist schon ein Investment, das ist sehr nachhaltig und das sieht auch eben so aus, als ob das mit der ganzen Kraft des Unternehmens geführt wird.
Ja, vor allen Dingen kommt es sehr von Leftfield, habe ich das Gefühl. Also alle anderen Machine Learning-Dinger sind, da kannst du dir halt ein Toolkit runterladen.
Was meinst du von Leftfield?
Leftfield im Sinne von, das kommt aus einer Richtung, die keiner erwartet hatte. Also es gibt so dieses Cafe und TensorFlow und wie sie alle heißen, diese Frameworks, die kannst du dir alle runterladen. Das ist eine Trainingssoftware sozusagen. Genau, da kannst du halt ein Machine Learning-Ding machen, aber jetzt so ein OpenGL für Machine Learning zu bauen und zu sagen, ja okay, Training ist eine Wissenschaft für sich, da habt ihr eure Frameworks, ist gut. Aber wir bauen euch jetzt mal eine standarisierte Engine in mobile Geräte ein, damit ihr eure getrainierten Netze irgendwie beim User ohne viel Schmerz fahren könnt. Das ist sowas, das hatte ich auch überhaupt nicht erwartet. Genauso wie das AR. AR ist auch so ein Ding, das dümpelte so vor sich hin, niemand hat das auf dem Plan. Plötzlich, bumm, kommen die da mit, machen eine Einbindung mit der Unreal Engine, mit den ganzen anderen Engines und plötzlich kannst du ohne viel Aufwand da ein Dinosaurier auf den Tisch stellen. Also das fand ich schon irgendwie...
Genau, was man jetzt mal klarstellen muss ist, Machine Learning ist jetzt nicht irgendeine Spielart von Computing, die auch ganz nett ist, sondern ich glaube, dass dieser ganze Machine Learning Teil...
Ist das neue Computing?
Es wird nicht alles ersetzen, aber erst mal macht es sehr viele Türen sehr weit auf, die bisher sehr verschlossen waren oder wo man überhaupt noch nicht mal dachte, dass da eine Tür ist. Heute ist nicht so lange her, wo wir uns noch gefragt haben, wird Spracherkennung jemals funktionieren oder so was? Oder werden Computer dieses und jenes verstehen? Jetzt ist absehbar, dass quasi alles, was mit Positives beworfen werden kann, was trainiert werden kann, dass das eben auch sehr gut durchautomatisiert betrieben werden kann. Und das ist etwas, was eine große Rolle spielt. Und wo spielt es vor allem eine große Rolle in eben dieser ganzen Echtweltnavigation? Das Auto ist halt auch noch aus dem zweiten Punkt extrem interessant für Apple. Gar nicht mal nur, weil man das jetzt als solches verkaufen kann und damit Geld verdienen kann, sondern schlicht weil eben das Auto, zumindest in den USA natürlich erheblich, aber durchaus natürlich auch in vielen anderen Ländern, ist halt auch so ein Ort, wo sich Leute viel aufhalten. Wo deine ganze Personal Computing Experience sehr, sehr, sehr wichtig ist. Ich meine, nicht ohne Grund gibt es CarPlay und dieser ganze Kram. Ja gut, die Fernsehserien, da weiß ich nicht, wie sehr das relevant ist.
Na, aber es zeigt doch auch, dass so was relevant ist, dass die Leute tatsächlich so ein Scheiß im Auto machen, sich dabei filmen und das dann auch noch ein Erfolg ist. Also ich meine, wenn jetzt Auto irgendwie kein wichtiger Ort wäre, dann würde das auch nicht funktionieren. Also ich sehe es mehr so als Symptom zu dem, was du gerade gesagt hast.
Also ich sehe Apple halt auch als eine Lifestyle und Design-Firma, die gewissermaßen das Lebensumfeld von Menschen in einem ganz bestimmten Ethos prägen und umsorgen möchte. Und in jedem Fall würde ein Auto dazu sehr gut passen, aus allen möglichen Gründen. Aber wie gesagt, sie haben jetzt, wie viele Apple Shops, was heißen die? Apple Stores gibt es jetzt auf der Welt? Hunde? Auf jeden Fall, sie haben eben da auch Erfahrungen gesammelt im Bereich, wie man halt Gebäude inszeniert. Also deswegen, ich finde es von ihren Skills, von dem, was sie gelernt haben, wäre es jetzt kein so großer Schritt, was ich eben nochmal gesagt habe, auch quasi andere architektonisches Umfeld anzubieten. Aber es kann sein, dass ihnen das zu blöd ist. Ich sehe es aber nicht unbedingt als eine Markenüberdehnung. Ich sehe auch den Helps-Bereich nicht als Markenüberdehnung und ich sehe ein Apple Auto auch nicht als Markenüberdehnung. Ich sehe nur nichts, weil dann hätten wir seit 4-5 Jahren hören wir vom Apple Auto und es kommt nichts. Und in diesen 4-5 Jahren ist wirklich grundstürzend viel in dieser Branche passiert. Und Apple müsste dann ganz, ganz weit von hinten anlaufen. Sie müssten von Anfang an komplette Robo gondeln, also quasi Autos anbieten, die komplett Level 5 autonomen fahren.
Ja, aber das haben sie halt verkackt. Das Projekt ist halt irgendwie versandet. Warum auch immer, das werden wir dann in 20 Jahren erfahren. Oder in 10, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich finde es eigentlich ganz interessant, was Gregor sagt mit den Gebäuden, weil ich finde halt auch so diese Apple- und Autogeschichte kommt mir zu wenig, aber sie haben echt viel in dem Homekram investiert.
Das Homekit?
Na ja, da finde ich passiert immer noch ein bisschen mehr als auf der Navigations-Autosache-Seite und dem Health-Bereich.
Also ich kann ja nur sagen, mit ihren Finanzkräften könnten die schon mal anderthalb Milliarden für eine Muster-Siedlung und sei es nur für ihre eigenen Mitarbeiter. Sie könnten ja so etwas nur als Test facilitieren. Sie wären ja nicht die ersten, die Großunternehmen, die für ihre eigene Belegschaft Siedlungen bauen. So und wenn das quasi schon für die Apple-Belegschaft funktioniert, gerade in so einem angespannten Markt, wie zum Beispiel im Silicon Valley, wo Hauspreise explodieren, könnten die quasi mit ihrem Geld unter Umständen noch ein paar interessante größere Siedlungsbereiche aufkaufen. Und ich halte es für möglich, um quasi dieses Apple-Welt, von dem sie offensichtlich träumen und das auch ein bisschen beängstigend ist, finde ich ja auch. Aber ich sehe da ein Potenzial.
Ja, aber wo siehst du da die Wertschöpfungskette von Apple?
Vor allen Dingen ist, dass nach wie vor der Hausbau weltweit sehr, sehr unindustrialisiert funktioniert. Das heißt, du kannst quasi mit einer Vereinheitlichung wahnsinnig große Skalierungseffekte leisten. Du müsstest natürlich quasi ein modulares Planungssystem haben, das eine gewisse Streuung mit reinbringt. Aber andererseits, jeder soll wissen, ich lebe in einem Apple-Haus, aber es muss trotzdem individuell aussehen. Das ist schon klar.
Aber das, was du gerade beschreibst...
Aber dieser Markt funktioniert ja. Es gibt ja den Hausmarkt. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass ein großer Player gewissermaßen, neben diese Hunderten von kleinen Developern, die es ja auch in Amerika gibt, also Typ Trump, das ist ja auch so ein Immobilientaikun. Davon gibt es ja in Amerika in jedem größeren Ort drei bis vier Leute. Das wäre ein Markt, wo ein Player wahrscheinlich durch seine Skalierung, durch seine schiere Größe einiges gewinnen könnte. Aber wie gesagt, es ist nur eine Möglichkeit.
Aber die Art, wie du meinst, das könnte man industrialisieren, da könnte man sehr viele Effekte herausschlagen, dadurch, dass man sowas in Massen produziert und, und, und, und, und klingt für mich ein deutlich stärker Indus. Also das ist mehr so ein Ingenieurs-Ding, wie ich es einem Elon Musk zutraue, als dass es ein Design-Ding ist, wie ich es Apple zutraue. Also nicht, dass Apple kein Engineering macht, was topklasse ist. Aber dieses, ich gehe von der Ingenieurs-Seite ran und sage, ich habe hier diese Lösung, die folgende Einspar-Effekte bringt, aufgrund dessen ich das und das und das und das machen kann, das sehe ich halt nicht so auf der Apple-Seite.
Auf jeden Fall die Schalter- und Design-Kompetenz haben sie für mich mit ihren Retail-Stores bewiesen. Und durch ihre generelle Designsprache haben sie viele Möglichkeiten, sich universell auszubreiten. Natürlich sollen die kein Monopole halten. Eigentlich haben sie schon im Bereich der IT-Devices schon ziemlich viel mehr Marktanteils. Das sollten sie wirklich nicht haben. Es gibt ja manchmal schon ein bisschen... Mehr Marktanteils, ja.
Sie haben eigentlich fast nirgendwo einen zweiten Marktanteil.
Na ja, ich gehe jetzt mal von so etwas aus wie hier St. Oberholz, wo du schon echt ein Parier bist, wenn du damit so einen Nicht-Apple...
Ja, in so einer Berlin-Bubble.
Na ja, ich kenne halt nur meine Berliner.
Er hat St. Oberholz gesagt.
Die Nummer mit dem Home und so weiter, das ist ein Markt, da werden die sich nie ansiedeln. Also nicht auf die Art zumindest. Bauen schon gar nicht. Und man sieht ja schon, wie schwer sie sich damit, mit dieser bisschen Elektronikinfrastruktur schon schwer tun. Was die Elektromobilität betrifft oder generell die Mobilität.
Exoskelette. Welche? Ja, für Leute, denen die Apple Watch nicht mehr langt.
Sie passen sich sozusagen dem alternden Publikum an.
Wie heißen diese so Transformer, der Apple Transformer?
iTransformer.
Ich bin da gerade nicht so ganz up to date, was so die Gerüchtelage betrifft. Aber das letzte, was ich aus diesem ganzen Projekt gehört habe, ist, dass sie irgendwie ihren Commuter-Bus zwischen Infinite Loop und ihrem neuen Apple-Park irgendwie auf autonomer Basis entwickeln. Also, ich denke, dass die da nach wie vor dran sind. Das haben die nicht eingestellt, das haben die nicht aufgegeben, so wie sie das übrigens mit vielen Dingen tun. Apple hat schon immer mehrere Technologien, teilweise über Jahre, verfolgt und am Ende dann irgendwann mal eingestampft, weil kein Markt, kein Nicht-Ihr-Ding, was auch immer, können wir nichts anbieten, was sich ausreichend lohnt oder von anderen Angeboten differenziert. Bei den Autos ist das natürlich eine sehr komplexe Nuss. Die Technologie wiederum, um sowas wie autonomes Fahren zu ermöglichen, ist etwas, was sie sich auf gar keinen Fall entgehen lassen. Wenn es nicht für ein Auto ist, kann es auch für irgendetwas anderes sein. Wenn es dein iPhone ist, das auf dem Fahrrad steckt und Dinge scannt, das ist etwas, was sie sich offen lassen. Dieses ganze Navigations-Ding ist für sie allein schon wichtig, weil sie ja im Prinzip auch schon alles haben. Sie haben Apple Maps, diese ganze Infrastruktur. Sie sind sowieso in diesem Markt da drin. Wenn sie Tesla ernst nehmen, dann müssen sie nicht nur sehen, dass Tesla jetzt mit einem Produkt Geld verdient, was sie gerade nicht machen, sondern dass Tesla auch potenziell in der Zukunft Geld verdienen könnte mit einem Produkt, wo sie sehr wohl sein wollen oder schon jetzt sind. Tesla kann auch ein potenzieller Gefahrkompetitor sein. Die können sich aus ihrer Position heraus noch Dinge erarbeiten, die wir heute noch nicht sehen. Ich vergleiche das mal mit Amazon, ein Buchhändler. Ein Buchhändler, der aber heutzutage allen Start-ups Computing-Infrastruktur baut, Server betreibt, megakomplexe digitale Dienste anbietet. Da hat ja keiner auch nur im Traum darüber nachgedacht. In Hinesight, wenn man sich das jetzt von heute aus anschaut, ja, total logisch. Um das zu machen, was sie braucht, müssen sie sich diese Technologie aufbauen und damit die sich besser rechnet, haben sie sozusagen alle diese Dienste, die sie für sich bauen, auch gleich automatisch für alle anderen gebaut. Großartiges Ding. So ziehen die das irgendwie auf allen Ebenen durch. Tesla denkt ja auch heute schon über das Auto hinaus, denkt über Mobilität, über Sharing, über irgendwie Mobilitätskonzepte, Vermietung von... Powerkonzepte vor allem.
Vertikale Integration.
Genau, und das sind alles Bereiche, wo auch natürlich Elektronik und vor allem dann auch Software eine riesige Rolle spielt und wo unter Umständen auch große Weichen geschaltet werden. Und ich glaube, das ist halt einfach mal für die größte Company der Welt nicht so ganz uninteressant. Zumal sich so ein Projekt, das können die sich irgendwie wirklich jetzt mal mit der Portokasse leisten.
Die könnten Magna kaufen. Dann hätten sie sofort einen kompletten Automobilhersteller, der keine Marke hat, weil er für andere arbeitet. Wahrscheinlich würden sie noch nicht mal die Fertigungsgeschichten verlieren, weil sie sagen, wir sind Apple, wir bleiben dabei. Wir brauchen das nur auch für unser Apple Car. Bleibt mal bei euch, wir haben hier Firewall. Und außerdem, wenn ihr uns rausschmeißt bei Magna, weil wir jetzt Magna haben, dann kriegt ihr kein Apple Carplay mehr. In Kanada und in Österreich. Also Magna Steyr ist so ein Automobil... Die machen alles. Also wirklich, du kannst da hingehen und sagen, ich hätte gerne ein Auto, dann entwickeln die dir das. Und du musst nur noch dein Badge drauf machen. Und die gehen halt nie diesen letzten Schritt, weil sie wollen sich ihre Kundschaft, was eben die großen Automobilmarken sind, nicht vergrenzen. Deswegen gibt es Magna Steyr als Marke nur in Österreich für das G-Modell von Mercedes. Das ist quasi, da sind sie mal als Marke.
So wie AMG und so, ja?
Nee, nee, noch viel kleiner. Sie sind quasi ab, weil dieses G-Modell wird schon immer schon bei ihnen gebaut. Und nur in Österreich, weil die da irgendwie so eine Tradition, war ja auch vor 30, 40 Jahren eine andere Zeit, das dürfte dann als Steyr Puch oder so was vermarktet werden. Und nur in diesem Bereich gibt es quasi Magna, nicht mal Magna, sondern dieses Steyr Puch als Marke. Und ansonsten, weil das ist ja ein Mini-Bereich und da halten sie sich schlau zurück. Sie wollten ja mal Opel kaufen, also Magna wollte Opel kaufen, da bekamen sie quasi Druck, vermute ich mal, von ihren Kunden, die gesagt haben, nee, ihr seid das Foxconn, also Magna ist das Foxconn der Automobilität.
Genau, und ich denke mir, das ist natürlich auch etwas, was Apple gut kann. Also gerade Tim Cook, wenn der irgendwas gezeigt hat ist, der hat globale Produktionen auf ein Level gehoben, wie wir das noch nie vorher gesehen haben. Also so viele Unternehmen, so weltweit, für solche High-Quality-Produkte mit solchen Quality Chains da hinzubekommen und dann auch noch mit Secrecy obendrauf, das ist ja das, was ihn überhaupt in diese Position gebracht hat und das ist das, was er bis heute in Perfektion dort ausführt. Und Auto bauen ist dann halt sozusagen...
Aber dann hätten sie das, wenn sie das vor zwei Jahren angekündigt hätten... Ja, aber ich halte das jetzt für sehr, sehr schlimm.
Also wenn jetzt Apple... Guck mal, jetzt haben sie... iPhone X ist jetzt mal raus, vielleicht erst mal die Luft ist jetzt erst mal raus. Jetzt stellen wir uns einfach mal vor, nächstes Jahr machen sie so ein Event, mit wieder mysteriöser Einladung. Alle drehen total durch. Diesmal haben sie irgendwie die Daumenschrauben aber auch so fest angezogen, dass die Leute auch noch nicht mal irgendwie in ihren Träumen nachts irgendwie daran denken, irgendwas zu leaken, weil sie wissen, dass sie einfach ihre Erstgeborenen einfach dran glauben müssen. Und dann kommt so eine Show und dann steht da so ein scheiß Auto oder ein Konzept. Du willst mir jetzt erzählen? Die Leute so ach nee, wir haben ja Tesla, Apple gucken uns nicht an. Mal ernsthaft. Klar, es ist kein Erfolgsgerät, aber dass sie keine Chance haben. Keine Chance haben die, der ist halt mit gar nichts. Also das ist, also können sie ihre Battles selber aussuchen.
Meine andere Sicht ist, sie wollen ja jetzt wohl auch in diese Content-Schiene einsteigen und da mit ihren etwas spießigen Moralvorstellungen, wie sie sich das im Apple Store schon angekündigt hat, glaube ich, wird das so Disney 2.0 oder bestenfalls Pixar, was ja auf Steve Jobs Mist gewachsen ist.
Naja, nicht auf seinem Mist, aber er hat es groß gemacht. Pixar gab es vorher schon, er hat sich da eingekauft.
Okay, da glaube ich z.B. auch nicht, dass sie, man könnte jetzt auch sagen, wenn Apple kommt und bietet super Serien für, was weiß ich, zu jedem iPhone, gibt es noch eine Serie dazu oder ein Abo für eine Serie? Weiß ich nicht, das kannst du auch nicht einfach so aus, jetzt gibt es Netflix, Amazon, jede Telekom der Welt will jetzt auch irgendwie Content-Anbieter sein. Da würde ich mich jetzt...
Ich frage jetzt ja nicht, ob du Content-Anbieter bist, sondern ob du Content-Produzent bist.
Ja, aber gab es doch so eine Nachricht, dass sie bei James Bond irgendwie mitgeboten haben? Also, ja, Gerücht.
Ja, wobei, ja, das weiß keiner.
Also da glaube ich, um ein Hollywood-Studio oder so ein Serien, ein neues Netflix-Konkurrenz, Apple muss auf diesem Level spielen. Sie müssen sofort aus dem Stand heraus quasi die Platzhirsche auf Augenhöhe herausfordern. Und das glaube ich zum Beispiel können sie nicht. Mit einem Auto meinst du? Also sie produzieren ja, ne, jetzt mal vom Auto abgesehen. Als Hollywood-Studio sehe ich Apple nicht.
Ne, ich auch nicht.
Ja, wo soll es denn hingehen mit Apple? Weder Hollywood noch Auto. Bauen dürfen sie auch nichts.
Keine Einzel.
Ich wäre schon froh, wenn sie mal ordentliche Tastaturen wieder produzieren würden.
Fliegende Autos, sie sollen fliegende Autos machen.
Tastaturen, das ist ein Zukunftsmarkt.
Drohnen, ja Tastaturen, genau.
Peak Tastature.
Wie sieht es denn jetzt eigentlich so aus? Wollen wir noch irgendwie unsere Restthemen noch irgendwie zum Besten geben?
Auch nö.
Ausputzer am Schluss.
Oder hast du noch was, was du noch...
Zumindest kannst du noch mal kurz darüber nachdenken. Oder?
Sprich.
Ich habe nur so eine kleine Sache, die ich auf jeden Fall noch erwähnen wollte. Und zwar der David, der unsere schönen Previeslees macht und jetzt ja auch wiedergemacht hat, wie ihr gehört habt. Ich sprach ja schon davon, dass wir das auch durchaus gerne sehen würden, wenn andere Leute sich auf das Thema stürzen. Und er hat jetzt mal quasi so eine Construction, Kids and Do-it-yourself-previously-construction-Sit, was halt aus den drei Teilen, den festen Soundbestandteilen besteht, gepostet, damit man im Zweifelsfall auch das notwendige Material hat, da entsprechend was zusammenzubauen. Das wollte ich hier auf jeden Fall nochmal mit einbauen, bevor ich das gleich wieder vergesse. An der Stelle natürlich auch wie immer gepflegter Dank an David, der das halt immer gerne macht, aber jetzt auch schon so lange gemacht hat, dass er sich glaube ich freuen würde, wenn er dann auch Verstärkung bekommen würde.
Das kann ich so gut nachvollziehen, weil er hat es wirklich immer gemacht. Immer, immer, immer.
Ja, das ist wirklich unfassbar.
Dann würde ich vielleicht noch wirklich noch mal kurz reinspringen, es sei denn, der Tim möchte ins Bett.
Ich möchte ins Bett, aber ich möchte natürlich auch gerne hören, was du noch so an Erfahrung eingesammelt hast in deinem Urlaub.
Genau, ich war wieder einmal in Schweden, oh Wunder. Allerdings nur relativ kurz, für vier Tage zum Wandern. Also ich fahre irgendwie jedes Jahr auf einem anderen Weg nach Schweden und suche mir einen Teil einer Strecke nach, von der Wandertour aus. Mein Ziel ist eigentlich immer so ein bisschen ultra leicht zu wandern, was aber immer ein grandioses Fail ist. Also ultra leicht wäre halt so, ich glaube, bis zehn Kilo.
Und eine Zahnbürste vielleicht noch.
Viele sägen ihre Zahnbürste ab, damit sie weniger wiegt. So deprimiert bin ich noch nicht. Ich habe mir das Ganze ein bisschen, also ich habe in der Tat so von Jahr zu Jahr alles optimiert, wo ich denke, dass man optimieren kann beim Wandern. Und wie letztes Jahr einen cooleren, leichteren, kleineren Rucksack, damit man nicht den ganzen Scheiß mitschleppt. Aber mein Highlight dieses Jahr war, dass ich mir Anfang des Jahres dachte, geil, hier hast du deinen Schlafsack, den du schon immer haben wolltest. So ein Sommerschlafsack, der wenig wiegt, also 320 Gramm. Also wirklich nichts, mein normaler Schlafsack.
Was ist da mal ein Link zu?
Ich hab einen 3-Jahreszeiten-Schlafsack als normalen Schlafsack. Und der ist so ein bisschen, ich glaub, der wiegt 1, 2, 1, 3 Kilo. Also wirklich ein bisschen was mehr. Das wäre mein Schlafsack, den ich mir geholt habe. Gibt es hier eine Vorschau? Nee, gibt es. Doch, gibt es.
Bergfreunden.
Bei den Bergfreunden irgendwie nur 330 oder 320 Gramm. Was natürlich super ist, was ich mir im Januar gedacht habe. Geil, kannst du wandern gehen im Sommer. Weil letztes Jahr hatte ich das Problem, irgendwie bei 34 Grad zu laufen. Ist auch nicht so schön, dann in einem dicken Schlafsack zu schlafen.
320 Gramm? Wieso steht so ein Feature nicht auf dieser Webseite?
Da oben gibt es auch so ein Stück weiter oben hast du so einen Teil.
Kunden sagen, leicht. Kunden sagen, gut komprimierbar.
Das stimmt. Also ich habe ein Foto, da muss ich mal gucken, ob ich das sogar auf dem...
Bist du ein Roller oder ein Knüller oder ein Falter?
Also bei den Rucksäcken knüllt man. Aber Rucksäcke knüllt man ja nur für die...
Rucksäcke oder Schlafsäcke?
Entschuldigung, Schlafsäcke knüllt man. Also man stopft die so in den Schlafsackfeutel hinein. Aber du nimmst sie zum... Wenn du sie lagerst, nimmst du das raus. Also du lagerst dann den Schlafsack offen in einem großen Sack, sodass...
Das höre ich ja das erste Mal.
Sollte ich auch mal machen.
Das ist wirklich wichtig. Ansonsten hat man ein Problem, wenn man das nächste Mal unterwegs ist, es verklumpt halt ineinander. Jedenfalls habe ich mir das Teil gekauft, sehr stolz gewesen. Hab es dann auf Festivals mitgenommen, was eigentlich nicht das Ziel war. Aber im Sommer hatte ich dann das Problem, so ein Schlafsack hat ja auch dann so eine Angabe, bis wohin man das von der Temperatur hin gut nutzen darf, kann, soll, wie auch immer. Bei mir stand dann dran 15 Grad. Ich guckte ja natürlich auf die Wetterkarte in Schweden, die sagte mir 12 bis 10 Grad. Dann dachte ich mir so, oh nee, diesen fetten Schlafsack mitschleppen ist überhaupt keine Lösung. Dann dachte ich mir so, Mirino ist ja schon ein geiles Stück Stoff, was dich wärmen kann. Vielleicht gibt es ja noch einen Thermo-Innenschlafsack. Weil Schlafsäcke benutzt man jetzt auch nicht unbedingt ohne Innenschlafsack, weil dauernd kannst du nicht so gut waschen. Also nutzt man den Schlafsack im Schlafsack, in dem man dann schläft. Der kostet so viel Asche, weil er in Deutschland genäht wird. In meinem Heimatdorf lustigerweise auch. Das wusste ich vorher aber nicht. Ich habe auch schon einen zweiten Schlafsack. Ich habe zwei Schlafsäcke von denen. Ich bin mit denen wirklich so was von zufrieden, wo ich sage, das Geld ist es mir wert. Den einen habe ich jetzt seit 4-5 Jahren. Ja genau, das habe ich mir auf die Fahnen geschrieben. Ich glaube, ich habe auch einen Yeti-Schlafsack tatsächlich. Mountain Equipment ist auch nett zum Schlafen. Das ist das schönste, worin ich bisher geschlafen habe. Ein Träumchen, genau. Ich habe dann lange recherchiert, damit ich diesen fetten Schlafsack nicht mehr schleppen muss, was es für Inlays gibt. Ich habe dann einen Inlay gefunden, der genau das erfüllt, was ich brauche. Er ist ein Thermoinlay. Ich habe verschiedene Inlays, schon ein Seiden-Inlay, was super ist für den Sommer. Der wärmt auch ein bisschen, das wärmt auch ein bisschen. Und ein normales Inlay aus ägyptischer Baumwolle, was ich zum Reisen mit dem Rucksack mitnehme.
Also das Inlay ist sozusagen, um einerseits den Schlafsack vor Schweiß zu schützen, den separat waschen zu können. Und außerdem macht er noch wärmer.
Genau, es kommt immer darauf an, was man für ein Material nimmt. Also Seide, wenn du ein Seiden Inlay hast, kann es sogar kühlen sein. Also dass es dich so kühlt im Sommer, dass es nicht so unangenehm ist, auf der Haut das zu haben. Also bin ich dann irgendwie mit diesem schönen Thermo Inlay losgezogen.
Bist du mit der Silk-Variante?
Hab ich auch einen. Also ich hab jetzt zum Wandern sogar beide mit gehabt, weil ich hab überlegt, was ist, wenn das dann doch nachts mal wärmer wird, dann willst du dich halt nicht wieder tot schwitzen. Und hab das Seiden-Inlay mitgenommen und das Thermo-Inlay wiegt so irgendwie 370 Gramm, schwerer als der Schlafzeug. Und dafür ist das Seiden-Inlay aber irgendwie so 130 Gramm. Genau, und der Radiator, das ist auch wirklich ein Radiator. Also ich hab einmal wirklich geschwitzt in dem Teil. Und dachte mir so, fuck. Und dann gibt es halt noch das unten ist das für den Silikon. Seidenschlafsack. Und damit kann man halt wirklich nochmal ein bisschen Wärmeleistung erzielen. Und ich mein, das Gewicht ist mir schon wichtig eigentlich. Aber was noch viel wichtiger war, dass ich halt nicht so viel Platz im Rucksack verschenke durch den Schlafsack. Weil dann kannst du halt auch schlecht irgendwo draußen ranhängen. Oder willst du jedenfalls nicht, wenn es regnet. Ansonsten geht der halt auch noch nass. Ist jetzt nicht so schön nachts im nassen Schlafsack zu liegen. Aber diese Kombination hat mich sehr beeindruckt. Ich schlaf halt für gewöhnlich in Schweden auch nicht in meinem Zelt, sondern die haben Wetterschutzhütten. Da bin ich immer zu voll, dann mein Zelt auszupacken und das in den Regen geben.
Wieso nimmst du dann überhaupt ein Zelt mit?
Wenn's voll ist. Also ich hab halt auch erlebt, dass diese Wetterschutzhütten gut besucht sind. Und wenn du deinen Schlafsack nicht dabei hast, hast du halt ein Problem. Also kannst du dir vielleicht noch eine Plane aufspannen. Aber wenn's dann wirklich anfängt zu regnen, also mein Zelt wiegt halt auch nur zwei Kilo.
Naja, aber ich meine, hier geht's ja wirklich um jedes Gramp.
Also ich hab ohne Essen und ohne Wasser 14 Kilo dabei gehabt. Und mit Nahrungsmittel, Wasser wahrscheinlich so 18. Also einmal definitiv 18, weil ich Wasser für den nächsten Tag mitnehmen musste. Konnte ich einmal nicht frisches Wasser holen. 18 Kilo, ja. Aber ich bin dieses Mal an der Küste langgelaufen. Das heißt, ich hab irgendwie einen kleinen Umweg über einen Berg gemacht, inklusive Kuh und Schafweide. Aber ansonsten bin ich halt eh relativ flach gelaufen. Da stören dich irgendwie 20 Kilo auf dem Rücken nicht so sehr, wie wenn du berghoch oder bergunter musst. Und wahrscheinlich bin ich dann so die meiste Zeit, ja die meiste Zeit wahrscheinlich so mit 16 Kilo, 16 Kilo.
Da fragt noch einer nach einem Link zum Zelt. Hast du einen?
Ich hab das unten rechts Modell, versteht sich. Ich hab mir mal...
Das Andere wird hier auch nicht besprochen.
Nee, ne, das dachte ich mir auch. Ich hab mir mal irgendwann den Luxus eines Hillebergzels gegönnt. Hilleberg ist so die Zeltmarke schlechthin. Tatsächlich. Und produzieren nach wie vor noch in der EU. Und jedes Zelt, was du dir kaufst, hat das Label darin, welche Frau oder welcher Mann das genäht hat. Und ich kann es halt nachvollziehen, wo das ganze herkommt. Also ich hab da mal einen Link dazu reingeschickt, zu meinem, ich hab das UNA, das ist eigentlich nur für eine Person ausgelegt, eine Person mit Gepäck. Wenn man aber zu zweit unterwegs ist und sein Gepäck draußen verstauen kann, kann man da auch dran pennen, zu zweit. Also wenn man schlank ist, wenn man jetzt nicht... Es sind 1, 10 Meter. Also das eigentliche Killer Feature an dem UNA ist, dass man keine Heringe braucht. Also wenn du auf einem Felsen mit einem Kanu unterwegs bist, also auf einer Felseninsel bleibst, brauchst du das nicht im Boden fixieren, sondern du kannst es irgendwie hochheben und hin und her tragen, was halt richtig cool ist.
Du bist jetzt nicht so ein Alleinstellungsmarkmal, das hast du ja natürlich bei anderen Zelten auch.
Genau, das hast du bei anderen Zelten auch, aber also Hilleberg hat halt so die beste Qualität, die beste Verarbeitung. Und als ich mal dann geschaut habe, dass so zehn Jahre alte Zelte, also das UNA im Speziellen irgendwie immer noch so zwischen vier und fünfhundert Euro waren, dachte ich mir so, okay, dann kann ich es mir halt auch neu kaufen. Das fand ich einfach ein bisschen, also hat halt wirklich gezeigt, die Dinger werden auf Expeditionen mitgenommen und auch die Expeditionszelte sind eigentlich so das, was du wirklich bei den meisten siehst, also die Expeditionen irgendwie im Kalten machen oder auf irgendwie, weiß ich, auf dem Everest.
Ich hab das ja früher auch sehr gerne gemacht. Auch immer so viel. So ein, zwei Wochen mal durch die Gegend gestiefelt. Eigentlich eine interessante Idee von Urlaub. Ich hab gemerkt, dass das, also jetzt wo du das so erzählst, ich hab immer das Gefühl, ich erinnere mich immer noch an jeden Meter, den ich irgendwie gelaufen bin. Das ist wirklich krass, dass man einfach durch dieses, durch die Welt marschieren, dass man da so intensiv seine Umgebung abspeichert, wie nur irgendwas. Gerade wenn man auch alleine unterwegs ist, da man die ganze Zeit so mit seinen eigenen Gedanken vollkommen unabgelenkt so total alles reinsaugt. Und das ist so eine Art Urlaub, die kann ich eigentlich echt weiter empfehlen.
Ja, ich hab halt auch gemerkt, also es war so ein bisschen vom Timing her so eine schnelle Aktion, sag ich mal, dass ich hingefahren bin. Und deswegen halt auch nur vier Tage. Was ich aber gemerkt habe ist, dieses Alleinerlaufen finde ich super, aber weil ich halt davor jetzt auch viel irgendwie unterwegs war, auf Festivals immer abends, auch mit Leuten meistens zu tun habe, ist das abends, oder wenn du an einem Rastort, sag ich mal, ankommst und du bist dann da alleine, das fand ich so ein bisschen, das hat mich manchmal ein bisschen, sag ich mal, erstmal mit runtergezogen, weil ich halt so das gewöhnt war, man war irgendwie unterwegs die ganze Zeit mit anderen Leuten, man tauscht sich halt so über den Tag einfach aus so Banalitäten. Ja, genau so, wo sind meine Homies? Geht das WLAN beim Zim noch? Ja, geht noch, wunderbar. Nee, aber das war halt so der einzige Punkt, wo ich halt gemerkt habe, so, oh, das ist ein bisschen komisch. Und war dann irgendwie an dem ersten Tag so irgendwie zwei Stunden, glaube ich, alleine in der Hütte, hab irgendwie Essen gekocht und so weiter. Und dann kam lustigerweise halt noch irgendwie mehrere Leute. Also es waren dann insgesamt so drei Grüppchen, also warte mal, ne, eins, zwei, drei, vier Wandergruppen bestehend aus eins, zwei oder vier Personen. Und wir waren dann jeden Abend zusammen an den Hütten. Und das war wiederum relativ lustig dann. Also du wusstest halt so tagsüber, ja, bist du halt unterwegs. Morgens hast du aber irgendwie Leute, mit denen du frühstückst, quatscht halt so ein bisschen. Abends hast du das halt auch. Und wenn du natürlich auch unterwegs bist, auf dem Weg und du triffst die, dann fragst du natürlich auch so nach, ist irgendwie alles in Ordnung, brauchst du irgendwie Hilfe, weil man weiß ja auch nie, beim Wandern kann man ja schon mal irgendwas passieren. Also ich hab auch schon die Erfahrung mit dem schwedischen Krankenhaus gemacht. Aber das mit der Blutabnahme, das können sie nochmal üben. Aber ja, ich weiß nicht, das fand ich halt echt schön, das hat Spaß gemacht. Aber so seinen eigenen Gedanken nachhängen, tagsüber, das fand ich schon... Ja, ich weiß nicht, das ist echt nochmal was anderes vom Urlaub her. Und ich habe das erste Mal, das habe ich vorher auch nie gemacht, Podcasts gehört, während ich gelaufen bin. Frevel, ja. Dieser negative Einfluss hier immer auf mich. Und ich habe es in der Tat halt auch vermisst, irgendwie nichts zum Einschlafen Podcast hören zu können. Das war so ein bisschen so, ich dachte so, ja, ja, hier fehlt jetzt was. Ich habe dann aber auch...
Ich brauche jetzt nicht welche Podcasts.
Ich habe viel Stuff You Should Know gehört, Podsave America und... Wrynd, das von Holgi, den Geschichtspodcast habe ich dann gehört.
Jetzt weine ich natürlich, ist ja klar, ne?
Entschuldigung, hast du einen Geschichtspodcast? Außer Focus Europa?
Muss es denn... also...
Also ich hatte, nee, ich hatte speziell was wegen Geschichte gesucht. Nee, ich hatte speziell davor nach Geschichtssachen gesucht, weil ich schon irgendjemandem einen Podcast empfohlen bekommen hab, der so irgendwie... was war denn das? Sechs Stunden ging?
Kein Problem, du darfst auch mal fremd hören.
Darf ich auch? Und natürlich hör ich auch immer Logbuch Netz... Ja, genau. Ich hab ein super Bild gehabt, wie ich Logbuch Netzpolitik gehört habe, aber da warst du ja nicht dabei, Tim. Also ich hab nicht mal fremd gehört auch im Urlaub. Schön am Strand gelegen.
Das ist kein Problem. Ich geh einfach nachher, verziehe mich einfach nachher in die Ecke und weine.
Nein, Tim, das musst du nicht.
Glaubt dir jetzt sowieso keiner.
Du weißt doch.
Nein, nein, mein Ego ist dafür viel zu groß.
Wie war das mit Gott und dir?
Solange er an mich glaubt, ist alles in Ordnung.
Nee, aber das war echt ein cooles Ding in Schweden, wieder mal alleine unterwegs zu sein und sich mal wieder weiter in die Thematik, wie komme ich noch leichter von A nach B oder beim Laufen generell, wie kann ich noch leichter unterwegs sein? Und hab irgendwie noch eine echt coole Begegnung an meiner letzten Nacht. Ich bin mit den Nachtferien gefahren in Schweden, also von Rostock nach Schweden rüber und auch wieder zurück. Und auf der Hinfahrt, also ich hab halt auch keine Kabine oder sowas gebucht, ne? Du hast ja eine Isomatte dabei. Und hab irgendwie die erste Nacht in so einem Raum irgendwo gepennt, wo halt auch andere mit ihren Isomatten lagen. Die haben da so einen Aufenthaltsraum gekapert. Ja gut, da ist noch Platz, ich leg mich mal dazu. Das Glück hatte ich aber auf dem Rückweg nicht. Und hab mir so versucht, ein Örtchen zu suchen, wo man vielleicht auch mal schlafen kann. Auf der Fähre. Auf der Fähre, wo nicht so viel Durchgangsverkehr ist.
Hast du ein Zelt aufgebaut?
Hab ich kurz darüber nachgedacht, draußen auf dem Sonnendeck. Hast du aber sein gelassen. Immerhin mach ich denen keine Kratzer im Boden.
Windsicher, irgendwie regensicher. Machst du keine Kratzer im Boden, richtig?
Hab ich darüber nachgedacht, dachte mir, könnte vielleicht blöd drüber kommen. Und hab dann irgendwie in so einem Gang geschlafen, was so nah an einem Crew Eingang war.
Hättest du eine kleine Deutschlandfahrt daran machen können, dann hätten sie wahrscheinlich Verständnis gehabt.
Dann ist es aber kein Ultralicht mehr.
Das international bekannte Zeichen für Beware of Germans.
Bei Elektromobilität. Die haben ihr Badehandtuch ausgegeben.
Jedenfalls fand ich ein Örtchen, das ein bisschen ruhiger war. Und irgendwann ebte auch die Flut der Menschen, die draußen auf dem Deck sich die Hafenausfahrt in einem Dörfchen angucken wollten. Was aber cool war, ich saß vor diesem Creweingang und einer der Maschinisten kam vorbei und wollte mir einen Kaffee anbieten. Nicht so, danke, ich will schlafen. Eigentlich. Und meinte er so, ja okay. Und der kam dann halt am nächsten Morgen wieder und meinte so, ach Mensch, du bist ja immer noch hier, ich hab dir was zum Frühstück mitgebracht. Und quatschte dann mit mir, der war super cool drauf. Und meinte so, ja weißt du, ich hab extra meinem Kollegen gesagt, der soll dich fragen, wenn er hochgeht, ob du nicht eine Führung im Maschinenraum haben willst. Ich guck ihn so an, so weißt du so, what? Ach, hätte dich das interessiert? Also wenn ich eins wissen möchte, dass diese gottverdammten Schiffe funktionieren, wie das halt da unten ausschaut. Also Brücke hätte mich natürlich auch interessiert, aber ich war in Maschinenraum.
Das war jetzt nicht so Briefmarkensammlung-mäßig gemeint.
Nee, nee, das meint halt wirklich so, eigentlich dürfen die das wohl auch nicht mehr. So Terror, Terror, la la la. Aber scheinbar sehe ich nicht aus wie ein Terrorist. Also, der meinte dann nur so, versuch das einfach beim nächsten Mal. Frag einfach mal irgendjemanden, der da aussieht, ob du dir so eine Schiffstour geben kannst. Aber da war ich echt so ein bisschen so geil. Das hätte ich eigentlich noch gern gesehen. So nachts irgendwie im Maschinenraum rumkriegen.
Das tut uns natürlich jetzt sehr leid, dass du nicht auch noch dazu gekommen bist, Letty.
Ja, das war wirklich tragisch.
Ansonsten für vier, fünf Tage durchaus Abenteuer.
Ja, das Spannendste war, wie man sich gegenüber Kühen verhält, die direkt auf einen zulaufen. War ich kurz irritiert, die Kühe auch.
Demnächst mit deinem iPhone X. Damit der Kuh kommunizieren. Moderne Kuhkommunikation.
Können die das dann auch in Kuh übersetzen? Also wenn ich rede...
Deswegen haben die wahrscheinlich auch dieses Kuh-I da eingebaut. Das ist Kuh-Intelligence.
Ich hab das einmal erlebt, morgens zählt auf und dann guckt die Kuh dich direkt ab. Du machst so im Halbschlaf, zack, und dann steht da die Kuh und glotzt durch. Und ich so, oh nee, ich steh noch nicht auf.
Ja, ich war auch echt so ein bisschen unsicher, wie man an denen vorbeischleicht. Ich hab dann auch nur gesagt, ey Mädels, sorry, aber ich muss jetzt hier vorbei.
Schon ganz schön beeindruckende Geräte, wie so eine Kuh. Das würde man schon eine gewisse Vorsicht an den Tag legen.
Hab ich bei den Pferden dann auch, aber die waren wesentlich chill da drauf. Aber das mit den Kühen war so ein bisschen cool.
Aber ich glaub, so ein Pferd tritt deutlich unangenehmer als so eine Kuh.
Ja, aber nur wenn du hinten rumläufst. Und das sollte man halt vermeiden. Also möglichst nicht zu nah am Arsch. Ansonsten.
Sonst hast du einen Hufabdruck.
Kann auch nett sein.
Die Kühe, die treten in jede Richtung, oder wie?
Die sind einfach stehen geblieben und haben geguckt und dir lange hinterher geguckt. Aber die haben nicht getreten.
Haben dich angeglotzt wie Kühe so glotzen halt wahrscheinlich.
Die dachten sich so, hast du iPhone? Nee, alles klar, geh weiter. Und das Schönste ist halt wirklich so, wenn man vier Tage in Schweden unterwegs ist, das schlechteste Netz, das man hat, ist echt 3G. Und eigentlich überall LTE. Und noch besser ist, also die Schweden haben es halt in jederlei Hinsicht raus, weil nicht nur dass du irgendwie an jeder Stelle, wo du schläfst, eine Wetterschutzhütte hast und in irgendeiner Form einen Wasserzugang hast und in irgendeiner Form eine Toilette hast. Nein, am Strand hast du auch eine Dusche und eine Wassertoilette. Und ich dachte mir so, ja, Luxusurlaub. Hat man teilweise ja nicht mal auf dem Acker, wenn man aufs Festival fährt.
Ich muss da auch mal hin.
Kann ich nur empfehlen?
Also ich war nur so ein bisschen in Malmö, das war dann aber auch alles.
Was ich nicht so empfehlen kann, sind die Regionen mit den Golfplätzen. Das ist so ein bisschen snobbelstort.
Die kann man glaube ich nirgendswo so richtig empfehlen.
Nee, aber dummerweise haben die halt so viel davon. Die stehen da irgendwie drauf.
Wollen wir mal zum Ende kommen? Das ist gut. Gregor, vielen Dank fürs Kommen.
Danke für die Einladung.
Tiefe Einblicke in die Welt der Gestalter und der allgemeinen Apple-Philosophie.
Wir wollen ja auch mal eines ganz normalen Apple-Anwaltes.
Wir sagen Tschüss, bis bald, ciao.